literally like
10 seconds before we started we blew a
fuse
in the studio and so i had to run down
two flights of stairs to hit the switch
and run right back
up so uh how y'all doing we're having a
good time i think today was the craziest
day in a really long time
bill barr apparently was fired or
resigned i guess depending on which
tribe you're asking a report came i got
hunter avalon in the studio
we are recording this so even though the
internet's giving us the business
okay yeah so we're going to are we going
to record this one and stuff it's still
recorded
okay yeah we're live hi everybody so
make sure you talk try and talk as close
as you can i might keep it with you and
uh
gotcha don't pound the table but uh who
are you what are you doing here
yeah well i'm here because uh you said i
could
i was like yeah come hang out yeah i
mean i um
uh i really built a fairly sizable
youtube channel by um
really talking a lot of right-wing
politics uh primarily social issues
that's really what i
primarily focus on even now um but yeah
i really i started off
pretty notorious for being a rampant
transphobe
uh i would be the type of person to tell
you that uh being transgender is a
mental illness
um you know getting your genitals hacked
off and all that kind of stuff that
would that was my whole mo right
um and it wasn't until later on as i got
a little older that i started to get
a lot more disaffected with my
experiences with the right
um and then it wasn't until april this
year when i decided to
formally announce that i had left the
right and i now consider myself more of
a centrist or center left
uh primarily because yeah i find myself
disagreeing with the right wing
on social issues a lot also just more
and more we have had so many people on
the show who are like
left the left former democrats so i
think it's rad that you came down man
thanks and i guess you weren't even that
far away to begin with so it's not like
too difficult not at all we also got
luke
caskey who just i guess he lives here
now he loves my parking lot
uh timothy why does this microphone
smell like a texas saloon
don't ask me what have you been doing
with it i don't know
who's here before me alex jones
it was alex jones hi guys luke and i
am the space troop commander behind the
youtube channel we are changed thanks
for having me and thanks for letting me
live in your parking lot
no problem ian's chilling hey everybody
yeah i'm here in the corner so this is i
don't even know where to begin today
i'm ready to just like put my feet up
like a cigar so i can't even smoke i
don't even drink but cigars and beers
yeah
a little bit of nicotine buzz okay let's
let's let's let's talk about this report
first
uh as many of you are aware we are not
allowed to make
specific claims on youtube they will
remove the live stream
but we have this report from allied
security group which got released
earlier today
a judge ordered it be released and it
let me just read you
one uh one quote from section b uh from
section b
subsection two saying we conclude that
dominion voting systems
intentionally and purposefully designed
with inherent errors
to create systemic fraud and influence
election results
the system intentionally generates an
enormously high number of ballot errors
the electronic ballots are then
transferred for adjudication
the intentional errors lead to bulk
adjudication of ballots with no
oversight no transparency and no audit
trail
this leads to voter or election fraud
based on our study we conclude that that
the dominion voting system should not be
used in michigan
we further conclude the results of
antrim county should not have been
certified
now let's talk about who this guy is
they say who we are the first guy
my name is russell james ramsen jr and
i'm a resident of dallas county texas i
hold an mba from harvard university
and a political science degree from duke
university i've worked with the national
aeronautics and space administration
and the massachusetts institute of
technology among other organizations and
have run businesses all over the world
many which are highly technical in
nature i have served on technical
government panels so this has been one
of the biggest stories of the day
interestingly if you google search this
and you try and look it up
you're not going to find the report
you're going to find a lot of articles
saying
unproven baseless trump supporters and
things like that
which is very strange framing for a news
organization because even if you don't
agree with this guy or you think he's a
hack or you think he's just trying to
help trump
you'd simply say an independent audit
you know
as the result of a lawsuit from
republicans made these claims
that's just the news if you want to
argue this guy is biased or right or
wrong
i mean you can but what's what's weird
is that you go on google you try and
find the story
they don't tell you what's in the report
they just say trump supporters
are pushing claims yeah
i know you hunter had some opinions
about this guy too so
yeah do you want that you want to
express those opinions yeah sure
absolutely in the marketplace of ideas
right
yes um yeah i mean i i don't
agree that we should just be like
attacking someone's credentials i don't
think that that's
um necessarily an argument against the
report i do however think that this
guy's credentials are important when we
talk about the likelihood of bias in his
report
so because he has been a republican
lawmaker i think or i know for a fact
that he's donated a couple thousand
dollars to
uh different gop people or whatnot um he
was hired by the trump admin
um and it's very uh very very frequent
for consultants to come to the
conclusions that
support the lawsuit so i don't think
that that necessarily
means that this report should be
completely ignored but i do think that
if anything what we should take that we
should look at this report with a grain
of salt
and take that uh maybe as an indication
that we need a
better more thorough and more
independent audit of these machines
i would 100 be in support of an
independent audit of dominion voting
machines because since i don't really
think voter fraud is
you know a big issue uh i would be more
than happy to see that audited and
hopefully the findings would you know
that's the right answer
yeah why has it been like pulling teeth
that you know because it had to go to a
judge to get this released why were the
why would the democrats try to block it
from being released
yeah i mean i i don't know i know what i
was what i read today was
i don't remember who said what but i
know that one of them said we're not
really trying to hide anything you can
go ahead and release the thing if you
want to
uh i know that the report is
it's it has a lot of misinformation or
at very least it has information that is
quite similar to previous
unfounded voter fraud claims that have
already been kind of debunked that's
interesting
wouldn't this bunk them what do you mean
so like if they said they were unfounded
claims isn't this founding them
well because they actually analyzed 22
machines right right well no because i
do think that this is extremely
susceptible to bias
and even more so i mean if do you want
to say no yeah i would question that
because
a lot of other people like john oliver
when it came to his show last week
tonight almost
last year made very similar claims on
his hbo show
warning us about dominion warning us
about the accountability warning us
about the numbers
almost very similarly to the report that
was just released by the republicans but
this was an argument being made by
let's just say the kind of leftist
establishment institutions when it was
against
you know this larger idea of russian
collusion so what do you think of like
other
proponents of the left saying this
election was a fraud
four years ago and now like john oliver
oddly kind of changing their minds
specifically john oliver about a year
ago produced a 20-minute segment
and targeted like a bunch of these
voting machines including dominion for
the susceptibility to fraud how very how
it was really really easy
now we have republicans saying wow look
at all this and now it's the
establishment left saying no no that
can't possibly be the case
i'm not too familiar with john oliver i
don't even watch him i don't really like
him very much to be honest um
i guess i would just want to know like
if you think that the if they have a uh
um an error rate of close to 70
do you think we would have discovered
that sooner than now
68.05 so i think just just to cite what
you're saying
the tabulation log this is from section
8. uh for the forensic for the for the
forensic examination of the server in
antrim county for december 6 2020
consists of 15
676 individual events of which 10
667 or 68.05 of the events were recorded
errors
these errors resulted in overall
tabulation errors or ballots being sent
to adjudication
the high error rate proves the dominion
voting system is flawed and does not
meet state or federal election laws
uh yeah we did find it texas rejected
the machines yeah i mean i
i i'm again i'm not familiar with every
individual you know talk show host or
texas or stuff like that but i do think
that um
when do you think that this is
susceptible to bias do you think that
guy sounds cool
absolutely yeah well as for you know
whether he sounds like he's biased
i think one simple thing is true do you
think he's lying under oath with his
with his presentation
was he under oath you know i believe
this is this is a sworn statement
presented to a court the judge has just
called me wrong you just wrote that
thing where he calls it proof yeah this
evidence that i have is proof
so that's a red flag it is i mean one of
one of his claims was that
i don't know if he was under oath
actually one of his claims was that he
um
was that the it was a a system error
rather than a human error yes voting
system right but i know that one of the
people i think it was a gop uh
eisenhower i don't remember his first
name um he was the one that
made the air he was a republican he made
the error and in andrew
yeah i believe so and didn't he even say
like acknowledge that
that he was the one that made that error
i can i can pull this up really quick
from where i'm reading from yeah see if
you can put up because i'm not super
familiar
uh my thing is like is this guy putting
factually baseless statements about
numbers and just like making up numbers
and then giving them to a court
you know yeah i don't think that i i i
don't like
there's no i don't think there's a grand
conspiracy i think trump certainly is
you know spitting and yelling but if
there's a grand conspiracy bill barr
would have just
launched investigations and done what
trump wanted and if he's under oath he
would go to jail
i don't know if he's under rose we don't
know yet but if he was which you know
most court proceedings most evidence is
under yeah i can't imagine perjury
you know yeah if he if he faked these
numbers and gave him to a judge
or present him to a court i can't
imagine no i don't i don't think that
he's just
like lying don't don't get me wrong i
don't think this guy's just making up
some
bs report and then just like lying about
it under oath or
whether he's under earth or not
regardless i don't think he's lying
about it i think that
he probably did do something one way or
another to get
that error rate as high as possible
uh now this is only a theory of mine
that i have because again we're kind of
still waiting for more info on this this
subject
as well um but i know that in antrim
county there were a lot of errors
at first that were then later fixed so
my thought process was
perhaps he was counting that error rate
before the errors were fixed
which could be a possibility um and if
he was that would mean that there's
probably a ton of errors in other places
that weren't caught and weren't fixed
i mean maybe this is why i would be all
for like an independent
non-partisan investigation i know that
dominion voting machines
have been under rigorous tests before
both state level and national testing
and have been rejected because of it
they have been in texas texas rejected
them after doing a test
when was this so i don't know the exact
year but when when dominion went to
texas
and said we want to use these voting
machines they did tests on them and said
whoa no way we can't use these
they're bad i would i would just want to
know how long ago that was i mean
yeah i know that in the beginning at the
beginning stages i'm sure that they were
much less unreliable but they've been
being used for a long time now
i think also that if we were if we were
using voting machines that had such
significant error rates i
kind of think we would have discovered
that sooner um
and again if his report was there's an
error rate and that's concerning that's
one thing
but the fact that he's trying to claim
that that's a system
fault it was january of this year texas
rejected the machines
yeah after they did tests on them from
the texan texas rejected use of dominion
voting system software due to efficiency
issues
i think that should be should have been
off oh we switched to satellite
oh good the light's turned off everybody
i think we're streaming
we blew a a fuse again we're gonna have
to run
some kind of like extension cable or
something but uh
there's the beeping is it oh look at
that we're still live
how are you guys doing does that mean
the pop-tarts are ready that beeping
is our reserve battery it just comes
with
beeping yeah absolutely there we go so
we have uh we have a reserve battery
so if the power goes out the cameras and
everything stay on but the lights turn
off because you know those aren't as
important
right well this is going to be fun um i
have no idea what's causing all that is
there anything we can we can turn off in
terms of power for something
to send a message to see if we can
figure out what's going on unplug some
stuff if you can
what were we talking about again the
power went out
that's right the power went out yes the
dominion voting stuff yeah
right right i i look for efficiency
problems so not necessarily
susceptibility to error
i think pretty important but that's a
pretty important distinction right at
the end of it if we all agree we should
have an audit
then we should so the other rv is
plugged in too can you unplug that one
it could be actually no one's in the rv
no nothing's being used
but it's there's no heater i have no
heat on i have nothing on in the rv
it can't be that same with yours just
unplug them just unplug both the ivs
yes yes i've had the power about at two
in the morning when i'm alone the only
one in the house away power keeps going
out everybody this is fun
uh we think it's luke's fault
it's easy to blame me for everything i
think we should just blame all the white
males here
personally yeah yeah yeah which is
everyone but me so i don't identify as
white
for me yes i'm an accuracy
an accurate i'm inaccurate luke you were
saying something
yes i was yes well i was saying how both
you guys made kind of good points here
there should be a bipartisan kind of
approach towards this but at the same
time we're in a
time crunch uh when it comes to big
companies overseeing this election there
should be a lot more scrutiny
a lot more oversight and uh i mean i'm
with john oliver there's there's
something that stinks with uh dominion i
think there's a lot
he changed his position he of course
changed his position now but i agree
with john oliver a year ago when donald
trump was in office
now that joe biden is in office i
disagree not in office
well technically he had a whole big
coughing speech today
yes uh which everyone's which everyone
is talking about on twitter just right
before the show went on
uh highlighting how he was coughing his
way through his
is that how they're gonna do acceptance
is that how kamala harris becomes
president that's it
i don't know but there's a lot of people
from left-leaning twitter accounts
saying
god i hope he doesn't have the
coronavirus from his latest speech
that's literally what i'm saying right
now maybe that's
maybe that's the next plan maybe that
well maybe that's the next big leftist
plan is to
infect biden with kovid so that he dies
and then they can boom get count
i mean that's that's basically been the
theory that was the plan all along
anyway that's what i've heard anyways
i saw a profile picture of biden and his
jowls are just like hanging down
i haven't seen him in profile lately but
man that guy looks wretched have you
noticed that like a lot of people in our
government look like they're just like
falling apart did you see that yeah
mcconnell with like his hand like
turning oh
i i love all the obese health ministers
they're my favorites
hilarious yeah and the los angeles
health minister as well
she i mean i i don't like to judge
people or or
comment about their personal looks but
if you're a health minister
you should look alive that's all i'm
saying i feel like nothing personal here
one of those things like
can you be a fat person who understands
like
health sure do as i say not as i do but
yeah but it's like
you want to set an example right i mean
do you guys remember
you guys ever see betelgeuse yes you
know the part where like they're doing
the uh
the exorcism and then alec baldwin and i
remember the ladies name
like they start like becoming really
decrepid and like then like i think it's
al baldwin's jaw falls off or whatever
that reminds me of like people in
congress yes you know
like joe biden like nancy pelosi like
mitch mcconnell who was the person that
was like their tooth fell out
i don't know oh that was a governor no
oh no louie gohmert
was that who he was yeah i know he was
talking and then like yeah
saw his tooth fall out it's like why are
all these people falling apart
because young people term limits because
yeah exactly
but i think young people are permanently
children
like younger people are like permanent
children now
so where where are the millennials
who are standing up and running for
office josh hawley actually we're the
gen xers
i think that's the issue there's like a
gap yeah we do have millennials yeah we
do i guess we have is rand paul
how old is he generating um i have no
idea
right now he's like 50 or something
that's crazy people are old now how
would he have to beat a boo
to be a boomer again it's like 60s is
that 60s yeah isn't that crazy
millennials are in their 30s how weird
yikes
what does that make you are you not a
millennial i'm not i've just missed the
millennial because i was born in 1996.
so i think i missed it by what was one
year yeah oh yeah yeah so i don't know
not a millennial what are you what is
that what are you
doing yeah you know gen z
is slightly more conservative than uh
millennials in some in some ways
yeah for the first time in like five
generations we saw a tick in the slight
other direction
they're still mostly progressive like if
you compare gen z to gen x
it's almost like like gen z is almost
the same as millennial in terms of where
they are politically
but they're slightly more conservative
in some areas sure
and i think that's probably due to their
being my
my guess is more conservatives more
conservative gen z than more liberal
not that their ideology has changed i
think it's just conservative parents
will have conservative kids
and because conservatives tend to have
kids more than liberals you're going to
end up with more conservatives
sure so there you go i mean i was an
example of that right i was a
conservative kid that's
yeah i was raised homeschooled i
actually think you're still conservative
i know can you could you explain that to
me or why do you think that well because
you're you're
uh advocating for the rights of private
corporations to
you know do as they please essentially
and i was arguing in favor of regulation
of corporations
right and honestly i and i will admit
that i haven't done enough research
into regulation specifically i am not
opposed however to something like
you talked about section 230 reform yeah
i would be okay with that
yeah i would be okay with with with
talking about that
but i think my problem is is when people
like trump say that we need to
get rid of section 230 protections when
it's like they just don't know what the
heck they're talking yeah he's stringing
himself up with it
that would be the end of all of these
conservatives if section 230 was going
like we wouldn't be able to have this
conversation live right now
well we would because i'm verified on
youtube ah
okay and that's the way it works the
elites are allowed that's what's coming
right do you guys see that pornhub
just nuked all unverified content luke's
not nodding because he probably
discovered it like manually
and destroying their brains and there's
a strong argument that a real opinion
there's yeah i mean
there's a strong argument to make
against pornography and the effects
especially on young children that it's
having that is rotting their brains away
literally i really i don't think i think
there's good porn
like one out of every 30 is good this is
personal this is anecdotal
but where they actually like each other
like okay
we're not talking about porn we're
talking about let's talk about how
you can't get a partisan a non-partisan
no no no no listen
we're talking about how pornhub nuked
all unverified we're talking about
bureaucracy
yes no we're talking about censorship
all unverified content was removed
youtube did this thing we started
pulling verification badges from
channels
i think youtube is listen it's a long
it's a long known and silicon valley
thing that you can't change the rules
overnight
when the famous story that i've told
many many times is that
ebay used to be yellow you probably
never heard the story i'll tell you
so the original ebay website was yellow
one day they said
yellow is like off-putting we're gonna
make the we're gonna make a white
background yeah
the next day everybody revolted they
were like the site's awful we hate it
what happened and they were getting
endless complaints from people
so they immediately changed it back okay
okay yellow then the next day
and for every day then on they slowly
incremented one tiny bit towards white
until a year later the website was white
no one cared you noticed
exactly no one noticed so what's
happening now i think is you see pornhub
does this and everyone's like well it's
pornhub whatever that makes sense right
because they were like there were crazy
accusations about you know trafficking
and underage girls
that i always i did always that's kind
of weird like anybody could upload stuff
to like to pornhub and i'm like
how do they verify the ages of these
people you know yeah i
used to think that same kind of stuff
like you probably got to verify that
kind of stuff
right especially if it could be
trafficking you need to make sure
there's you know these people are
concerning this stuff
but then i just think what's going to
happen with youtube
they did the the the verification
removal wave where all these channels
got their badges removed actually if i
could just
really quickly cut in because i remember
that happening because i was actually
one of the creators that got contacted
by youtube and i was told that
that my creator badge was gonna be taken
um
and i was like pissed af about it
obviously uh and then youtube
quickly said they weren't going to do
that yeah they because there was an
outro
there was a revolt right and that's the
point right right how is that censorship
though
well censorship is just like you know
hiding information
yeah but like taking the checks away
wasn't that's not censorship so it's
it's frogs in a pot right
now uh since since then they've been
pulling people from the partner program
instead of doing a wave of removing
badges they said okay
we got to do it one by one individually
to random people in different
communities so that
no one gets angry and starts a news
cycle about it since then
they've purged tons of channels this
year alone youtube said in their own
statement 8 000 channels have been
deleted
yeah so that's how they slowly start
getting rid of without causing an uproar
the reason i bring this up is in term
you know in the text in 230 conversation
yeah what i think is going to happen is
eventually youtube's going to be like
you have to be verified to produce on
youtube so that's why i said we'll
probably be fine
because i am a verified youtube channel
they never threaten to take my badges
away
they you know i have direct contact with
people at google they tell me like when
there's rule changes i can call them and
they clarify and then you know
they they like me in that regard because
i'm rather milk toast i suppose
well the boiling the frog analogy is
good because not a lot of people know
this but scott adams and jeff berwick
just had their channels totally taken
off
and just like you you said same thing
kind of happened to me but then they got
rid of my partner program later on and
i'm like wait
what's going on here and another
important thing that youtube announced
is that
they also will start putting
advertisements on
channels that are not in their partner
program anymore so they could put
ads on mine and i'm getting comments
saying hey there was an ad i'm happy i
got you know i was able to watch it for
you luke and i'm like
i'm not in the partner program anymore
and that just happened a couple days ago
are you verified like
a check mark i used to be verified i
believe they took it away as well with
the partnership program yeah
so so i think i think one i think what's
going to happen next
is they're probably not going to say
anything they don't have to but
channels that don't have verification
probably already
are de-ranked in the algorithm yeah i
i can't speak for for i know i can't
speak from anecdotes but
god my channel is doing horrible right
now and i'm verified
so but that's because you like that's
because i left the right right well yeah
if you build an audience up where you
say something like you know backflips
are the best
and then all the backflip fans are going
yeah and then you change i was wrong
front flips are better they're going to
be like boom and that's exactly what's
happening to me now is that yeah but if
you know start purging my audience of uh
yup
farther right people unfortunately have
you thought about making a new channel
no because um uh no
it's it's challenging enough right now
to try to manage the one
um and it's just like like when i
when i announced that i was leaving the
right having built you know a
conservative audience i knew that was
gonna be extremely controversial and i
knew that it was going to be
pretty detrimental to my career for the
time being also as far as like view
counts and everything goes
um which is one of the reasons why i get
really frustrated when
people call me a grifter they say that i
just ditched the right and joined the
left for the money or whatever and i'm
like
i lost like 50 000 subs so far for
acknowledging that i'm no longer that i
no longer really align with the right i
think the hardest thing would probably
probably be
to just choose to be wrong you know yeah
it's it was hard to
i'm kidding oh really i was making us
no no i'm sorry i thought you meant
choosing to acknowledge that you were
wrong no
no well i guess that's a good point
because i did do that i didn't decided
to leave the right i'm kidding by the
way what did you what did you take start
to take issue with
that you used to believe uh well i
started well
okay i started taking issues just with
the right wing kind of in general first
which
and i i know that you know conservatives
they're very broad
i'm not putting i'm not trying to
prescribe this on all conservatives by
any means but
my experience anyway i felt like
especially the further right you went
uh tradition took precedent and so it
was tradition over
really anything else even if that was at
the expense of other people's rights
so i have a total problem with people
who although maybe not conservative
would be
far right uh having a those people being
against gay marriage because it's not
traditional trump's four gay marriage
and he was pro-gay marriage before he
even uh ran for
before he ran and then he was the he's
the first president to be pro-gay
marriage before becoming president
yeah so like he entered office he had a
famous photo where he's unfurling the
lgbt flag but that's not like he's but
that's the promise that's all he's done
he's done he's been very detrimental for
the lgbt community
well but maybe the gbt community but i
think there's a lot of
lesbians that are actually very very
much in support of him he actually has a
really large base of gay men too
interesting peter thiel spoke at the rnc
and that was the first time a gay man
spoke at the rnc
more importantly trump gave a speech to
the rnc and got the republicans to clap
and cheer for the
for the lgbt community that was i mean
you know that may just be
clapping it's not really policy it's
virtue signaling honestly because what
trump's doing is he's signaling to this
virtue that he's pro-lgbt but yet
now that he's been in government they
tried to uh the trump trump
administration asked the supreme court
if they could stop gay people from
adopting despite there being
repeated longitudinal studies which show
that
kids raised by gay parents do not fare
worse than their
um straight couple counterparts did he
ask or did he do it
well he wanted to do it so a lot do we
know that for sure is that source
yeah you can look it up trump went to i
believe it was donald trump went to the
supreme court if you want to look that
up
um again i don't know all the details
off the top of my head so i'd love to
have more info right here but
was there a wait wait i think are you
referring to
when he said adoption agency should be
able to reject gay couples
how long ago was that so this is june
4th of this year
i thought it was more recent than that i
thought he was talking about a time
specifically where he wanted to
taxpayer-funded organization should be
able to refuse to work with same-sex
couples and others
whom the group considers to be in
violation of its religious beliefs
yes i'm not saying i agree with it i'm
just here's the specifics i think that
that would still kind of fall in line
with
violation of lgbt rights especially when
you talk about like
there are a bunch of kids in our foster
care system right now there and
and gay couples obviously are far more
likely to adopt because
they can't have children so you do
surrogates or you know
well yeah you can do surrogates but also
there's a lot of kids that need homes
that need
loving parents and i i'm i have two
children
uh i'm a dad and i'm married and i i am
a strong proponent of the nuclear family
actually that this is one of my most
conservative traditional viewpoints
so you're pretty anti-black lives matter
then no i know
i know where you're going with that
though what do you mean like one of
their core tenants is disrupting the
nuclear family i don't know if that's
one of their core types
on their web it was on
i'm not saying like an individual who's
cheering for i'm saying like the
organization itself yeah
i don't like the nuclear family and i
don't like blm organization
but what i was saying is so i was right
well i like blm the movement but not the
organization well those are funny
organizations so you agree sure sure
yeah
um but yeah no i'm a big proponent of
the nuclear family but what i always say
is that the nuclear family is just two
parents
raising children it doesn't have to be a
straight couple raising their parents so
raising the kids so science actually
agrees with you on that one yeah they
they haven't been able to make a
determination if it's male and female
or just two parents and i think
like simply put if we can get kids who
are
in orphanages or you know who need to be
adopted to any loving family
like that's preferable to having a
homeless kid who's living in the system
that's terrible
right so i you know but but yeah there
was a report that came out where that
said like the science so far that we've
done
can't determine between male you know
traditional like parents of like a male
men and a woman or
a you know same-sex couple right and
that the children are benefited equally
as far as we can tell
so far right so far exactly and i know
that yeah
i don't know if it's the same study or
another one but i've looked at ones too
that showed that they
usually actually when children of gay
parents um
fare worse it's because of like social
stigma because of the gay parents
uh not so much like because anything to
do with the gay people necessarily
but yeah i mean that's one instance i
guess of donald trump um
expressing some anti-lgbt sentiments
just one of them
i i don't think that trump is like this
malicious anti-gay
president um but i also think that he's
a bit virtue signaling when it comes to
that
trump we're just saying a lot yeah yeah
like tweeting repeal section 230
uh it's a really really bad idea but
he's trying to let conservatives know
like i'm fighting for you and it's kind
of like but
you're giving them what they want when
you say that like right these democrats
would
are are like no wait trump don't
because they want it to happen they want
230 gone said he wanted to imprison
people that desecrated the flag
yeah that was stupid insanity yeah so
but a lot a lot of conservatives agreed
with him stupid virtue signaling
if it's your property and you want to
burn it so long as you burn it safely i
got no problem either virtue signaling
or pure idiocy
yeah see that's that and that was one of
the that's like another
thing that i was really concerned about
with trump is just his approach to free
speech with
with his calls to repeal section 230
with his calls to uh to make it easier
to sue media companies
um right so like what we were just
talking about i think that
well showing media companies isn't a bad
thing it could be if it could be
more libel laws and stuff i mean yeah
that was definitely the stop
criticism of him i believe well the
issue is that
there's a really tough standard right
now from a ruling called times v
sullivan
where media outlets you have to prove
they knowingly lied
and it almost never even gets to the
point where you can right so there's
there's things called anti-slap laws
basically
the new york times could publish
whatever well here's a better example
the today show outright lied
they used clever language and how they
lied and if i did sue
they'd just be like get out of here but
i'm like if we went to discovery
if you allow this case i might find
their messages where they say
hey does this sound you know legit
because i know it's not true who knows
what they're saying behind the scenes
but you never even make it there so i
definitely think there's room to
solve some of these problems i actually
think the solution is if there's a
defamation
i should be able to sue for a correction
if i can prove
it was false that means even if you make
a mistake
i can say i would like you to correct
this if you say no i can sue you and the
relief from the court is
publish the correction if it's proven in
the court to be true but we don't even
have that right now so something has to
be done
yeah absolutely and you know i know
before we went live you were showing me
some examples of like media bias and
stuff and
i would never deny that the media is
incredibly biased and
it just i mean it would depend on the
publication also but i like your idea
with the defamation thing that would
yeah that makes a lot of sense actually
because it's weird right now where
a news organization will publish
something false and then someone will
sue and say hey
or someone will complain it's false and
they'll say well we're not going to
correct it it's like
if come on like that's just dirty yeah
yeah it's but you can't sue for that you
should be able to i don't know how you
get to that point or how a
if you did would they have to pay for uh
court fees as well
yeah if you proved it to be false then
they should be responsible for the court
fees
because that means before you went to
court you attempted to resolve the
problem
so or i i should put this way you know
if you don't attempt to resolve it then
maybe
no but if i contact you and say hey this
article is incorrect here's the proof
and you say f off
okay i'm going to sue you and when i win
you'll be responsible for court fees if
they say f
off well then it's their problem what
about damages no okay
uh if it's not intentional and you can't
prove it
that's that's the problem like if i say
something like you know ian crossland
was wearing a don't say it
wearing a blue sweater don't defame me
like that and i was just like
you know what i made a mistake because i
so the lights were awesome
the lights were off and it was an honest
mistake then we
we need that leeway for error yeah
otherwise news organizations couldn't
function
but we can't allow them just be like i
lied and you can't do anything about it
that's where they're at right now right
yeah i mean i i definitely think that
like there's there's room for
conversation there but i think that
donald trump's calling to repeal
libel laws and the way he set it to so
we can make a bunch of money or whatever
i don't
i don't think that it was coming from a
sincere and nuanced perspective
like what you have i think that it was
coming from media companies are
criticizing me and i want to be able to
sue them easier
i mean i don't know you you talk to a
trump sport i'll tell you one thing you
talk someone hates trump they'll tell
you the other so as far as i
i can tell is i just assess it on the
merits is there a good reason to go
after these these you know the current
system absolutely it's kind of messed up
yeah so i just you know well i'm glad we
agree on the the flag burning thing
though you agree that that was
oh yeah so it's a it's it's you know
traditional the the left and the right
in this country have
uh have flipped it's what are they
calling it's the realignment i guess
yeah the flipping or the realignment so
like uh
you know 10 years ago for instance
julian assange biggest hero to the left
right now they hate his guts uh a lot of
leftists
do however want him pardoned as well so
it's it's more like the neolib
establishment left who we're never
really the biggest fans of him for the
most part anyway but
nobody likes them yeah but they're
they're the establishment i think what
what really happened is that when trump
got elected
the establishment cronies from the
republican party went to the democrats
their next closest alignment
but we are seeing an interesting
alignment where like um i guess
you voted uh is it publicly you voted
for yeah you voted for joe biden
yeah see like for us we're i think 10
years older than you
that would never happen that's like
because uh bush is essentially a neocon
he's a he's a warmonger he's a you know
an
interventionist he as part of like the
obama administration prosecuted more
journalists and whistleblowers
uh on you know than any other under the
espionage act more than
all the other presidencies before him
combined yeah so so
the left has become like even uh like
the left has become the authoritarians
it used to be that the republicans
like when i was growing up were the
moral authoritarians and the
authoritarians george w bush started
these wars
and they wanted to ban like i've got art
downstairs
where it's from the card game magic the
gathering and in the 90s
the right got some card art band had to
be changed today
the the band cards i have now came from
the left getting art banned
so it's like you know it's flipped the
the left is now
uh very much so in support of these uh
intelligence agencies for the most part
they're supporting joe biden he's
stacking his cabinet with lobbyists and
corporatists and goldman sachs
all of the worst corrupt people
imaginable
and it's like that that's exactly why i
voted for donald trump
there's a reason why i went down to
occupy wall street and i was like
you know the system's broken and there's
a reason why i'm like
joe biden's a bad guy because joe biden
was vice president during occupy wall
street
when all of these leftists were coming
out and complaining interestingly enough
too
you know in 2016 we had the rnc in the
dnc right
do you know uh uh the left didn't
protest the republicans
do you know they protested yeah the
democrats really the left showed up in
the thousands
tried storming the barricades to break
into the dnc nobody went to the
republican convention
trump was down there i was in where was
that was that was that
florida no no 2016. that was um
cleveland it wasn't atlanta was it no
i don't remember charlotte yes there was
one in charlotte yeah
well trump was there and he's like you
know uh giving a speech to republicans
where he says
the you know these people uh and you
know he i think he's talking about the
pulse nightclub shooting he said
there's a lot of people who have
religious differences with this group
but these are americans these are our
people and they were attacked
and everyone starts clapping and
cheering meanwhile the democratic
national convention bernie sanders gets
ripped off
and the left is like trying to knock the
barricades down and jump over and storm
into the building
so the left was protesting now the
weirdest thing happens is you get like
these
faux progressive corporate you know
independent commentators
on youtube and such who are just like
the machine is right
i you know my favorite thing is is how
like rage against the machine the band
is very much rage for the machine now or
rage on behalf of the machine
they used to say things like what's the
famous line f-u don't tell me
i won't do what you tell me now they're
saying fu you better do what we tell you
yeah how so so uh like lockdowns for
instance
the left is very much in favor of the
lockdowns and a stimulus
like that's the antithesis of where the
left would have been a while ago
definitely in favor of more socialist
policies and stuff
but not letting the government just
decree
that we're going to bar you from leaving
your homes which they're doing and
they're cheering for
i think my favorite thing about like joe
biden is when he said trinidad
a pressure and the audience was cheering
for him it's like now that's something
remarkable shout out to cassandra
fairbanks for pointing that out
yeah yeah yeah it's like everyone's
cheering what are they cheering for
so weird or bad at cath care i think you
know what happened is
i think uh you weren't old enough and i
mean there's no disrespect you're 24.
that's fine you're 24 right yeah
you like so like luke and i went through
occupy wall street
luke actually questioned democrats on
barack obama drone bombing kids
and things like that and either got lied
to or had people say like yeah well he
should have a better father
who was that was that gibbs yep that's
barack obama's spokesperson
horrible yeah i mean obama obama was the
veep i'm sorry biden was the vp
he was overseeing iraq and his brother
got a lucrative multi-million dollar
contract for construction deals
it's like the the amount of evidence
that's come out against the bidens and
it's just like completely ignored by the
left because
either they're just tribalists who don't
care and so they're like
i just want to win and it's funny
because they're the ones saying the con
just want to own the libs i'm like dude
you just want to own the cons it's all
you want to do
it's so funny hearing you say this
because with my experience i've
i feel like i've seen the same exact
thing happen on the right oh the right
just wants like
like they want to own the libs and there
are people who go on twitter and just
do you think that the right is like
heavily ideologically driven
like i've seen i've found that the right
tends to
already have kind of a set of like
presuppositions and then they go out of
their way to find
uh support for their already held
beliefs rather than the other way around
which is
trying to approach it neutrally and then
forming your opinion based
that's both the left and the right do
you think it's both it's absolutely
terrible
yeah so like oh yeah like and i would
agree that it's both for sure that's why
i mean that's why i like to
but right now right so so right now the
right has
more of the critical thinkers and it's
cancelled culture that's basically why
so
you'll see like i was down at occupy
wall street wasn't really
i didn't agree with a lot of them
because they were very just like they're
extremely racist people like some it was
one of the most racist things i've ever
experienced at occupy
and uh but there were a lot of economic
populists there who weren't necessarily
in line with the weird racism stuff and
there were fights over it
the the i think the left has become like
predominantly racist relative to where
the right is how so
so uh occupy wall street they segregated
voting blocks based on race
well that i just can't even speak on
that since but would you agree that's
racist
to be like we're going to allow you to
vote for how things are run here
but we want all the brown people here
all the black people here all the
mexicans here and all the asians here
and you're all separated based on your
color and you can vote
only one vote per group no matter how
many of you there are wow
so if you have like you that's fair no
no i said that's weird
oh right right right so that's that's
that so that's what's like what's
happening at these universities with
like critical race theory stuff
so they'd be like there's 10 white
people three asian people and 15 black
people you all get one vote based on
your race
so you get three votes but that makes no
sense because there's different numbers
of people
that's what occupy was doing it's
extremely racist
and so that's when i started being like
well this crazy stuff man anyway
the left has become particularly
authoritarian in
in their application of things well how
have they become authoritarian uh
besides are you and are you yeah the
lockdowns uh so so you also have
cancelled culture right but censorship
supporting massive private corporate
corporations
corporations are are essentially
authoritarian structures
i'm i'm gonna have to ask you more about
this i'm such a leftist you're such a
conservative no it's okay it's just
how are the leftists supporting um
corporations
uh censorship i mean trump gave
tax cuts to corporations right he gave
taxes to everybody it but
substantially more so to the
corporations but what is what what's
wrong with that
uh well that's actually fairly
libertarian well no the problem with
that was that
he was going in there hoping that by
lowering corporate taxes we would see
more businesses coming back to the us
but that's just not what happened
well the economy did do ridiculously
well in 2019 but that wasn't because of
trump
why not who was it because of it was
because it's an economical fact that
after a recession the economy always
comes back stronger
after a recession 10 years ago yeah go
ahead look up the
go i'm not saying you're wrong i'm
saying if you can't give it credit to
trump then you can't blame george bush
for for the recession you can't blame
obama for the recovery
what did trump do to help with the
economy what did trump do is more
specifically even to help with
unemployment tariffs
uh there were there were immigration uh
raids on
processing plants which resulted like
it's it's a variety of factors but
tariffs didn't do
that that cost american taxpayers
hundreds of thousands of dollars
in subsidies per job bringing back to
the us
right that's that's true that's the
point that's how the economy works so
if if you want to save money for the
businesses and the elites
then you allow them to send
their jobs to china for instance where
they pay people garbage and there's
human rights abuses
lowering uh so so let's take a look at
what joe biden his plan is there's two
big things he wants to increase the
minimum wage to 15
an hour and he wants to raise corporate
taxes by about 10 percent
if you go to a corporation a
manufacturer say someone who makes socks
and say we're going to raise your taxes
by 10 percent you've got to pay all of
your employees 30
more they're going to be like dude
you're squeezing me dry
i can't afford how am i supposed to do
this don't worry don't worry
we're going to have a free trade
agreement and you're going to be able to
run your factory in china
that's what that's what that's what
obama was doing and that's and it worked
so when was the last time minimum wage
went up
very very long time ago so so should it
be increased
no even though it hasn't been adjusted
for inflation or anything yes
so the there's a bunch of problems
outside of what the
outside of the minimum wage and the
minimum wage is not a solution to the
problem
if uh so uh you need to sit down and
talk with like a small business account
that's exactly what i did to better
understand the issue
i talked to an accountant who
represented like 300 small businesses
and i said we have a problem because
people don't have money to spend
right if they can't spend money
businesses can't take in money then they
can't pay taxes and they can't hire
people so we want the machine to flow
and he and yes completely correct
however
a hard increase of 30 or so because this
is what we saw in new jersey he said
here's what happens
he's like i just lost 30 of my clients
they shut down their businesses why
these people who run these small
businesses they're corporations too and
they have like 10 employees
but the owners aren't rich by any
stretch of the imagination
they might be paying their employees 10
bucks an hour because all they can pay
and then the guy who runs the bus is
only getting 50 000 a year
he's making a modest salary for him and
his family well then also they come in
and say increase your
your your wages your your your your
costs by 30
plus employment taxes right and all of a
sudden this guy's only been making 20
000 a year and he says i can't afford
that i'd rather just go work as a
manager you know a
corporate for walmart or something so
that that has the impact esp
specifically in new jersey when they
pass this laws when i talked i went to
an account to ask him
you know tell me what's going on he said
he lost a ton of business accounts were
canceled and businesses just shut
overnight
you can't force the economy to just
increase
there's one good thing about the minimum
wage and it's about exports
if everybody in the u.s is getting 15 an
hour
that means everybody can afford
something made in china better
and that's been one of the biggest
strategies of joe biden if we increase
the minimum wage increase corporate
taxes
we'll have all of our factories go to
china because joe biden and obama were
very much in favor of
you know these free trade agreements
notably the tpp and now the new
agreement that they've recently uh
negotiated without us
joe biden's gonna get us in that day one
we're gonna lose our jobs here
but the good thing is it will it will
make it so that
somebody who works at mcdonald's who
makes 15 bucks an hour can more easily
afford
afford the iphone made by the slaves in
china see i think that's horrifying and
ultimately it's a downward trajectory
where we lose all of our jobs and then
eventually america just
sustains itself off of printing petro
dollars and that can only work so long
as we're blowing other people up and
threatening them that if they you know
disagree with our
say building an oil pipeline or natural
gas pipeline through syria
then we arm the rebels in syria to
destroy the government and wipe out
whole cities
which is basically what happened right
right but i mean i don't think that
like all the corporations would go to
china
no the manufacturing ones the ones that
could maybe so trump you know that
just out of curiosity for the joe biden
uh 15 minimum wage do you know if that's
just across the board or does that only
want certain corporations
uh i don't know for sure and to be
honest i don't think he would do it you
know you know
i think he would fail and you would try
what you should do instead is give
employees like a percentage of corporate
profit that way they only get extra
money if the corporate that's bernie
sanders policy yeah
that way it wouldn't extort the business
wouldn't run them out of business
because they're already making the money
that i completely disagree you know
that's like uh isn't that market
socialism
is that what it is that's bernie sanders
bernie's platform that's like worker
co-op
right where everybody works completely
completely bad idea but keep it you have
to do it
i am not educated taylor form i'm not
educated in that i'm not about to
support or deny you know do you know why
the farms failed in these
socialist revolutions in these communist
revolutions depends on the revolution
well like because they made a basically
of scientists go do the farming
a bunch of artists and they didn't know
how to farm exactly
and they killed birds and they killed
birds that was funny yes and they told
everyone to like melt down their their
tools or whatever like this is a bunch
of weird weird stuff
uh when you take a bunch of people who
don't know how to do something
and then give them control over a system
and they can't
do it it fails yeah we saw that in
zimbabwe we saw that in china with the
sparrows being killed out wiping out an
interview yeah so socialism
i feel like i see that even with the
trump administration i mean how so trump
has put a lot of people
in positions of power that are not
preferably qualified are not
oh he did like john john bolton is
definitely the biggest one
jared kushner i mean i was doing i don't
know jared kushner negotiated these
historic peace deals
so i was looking into it man and jared
kushner and all that kind of stuff it's
it's pretty corrupt this is his
daughter's husband yeah it is
donald trump has literally donald trump
has actually used the establishment to
line his
own pockets how uh well for one donald
trump was
because of his position in government he
well first of all let me let me back up
here
when donald trump uh was facing you know
critics and stuff he said that once i
become president i will not do any more
business dealings
um and he passed his business down to
eric and
don jr um fast forward a little while
later and there is a
complex it's worth 33 million dollars
and it's a government subsidized complex
okay
but the trump uh i guess eric and don jr
technically
want to sell this along with a bunch of
other real estate as well
well it's a government subsidized
complex right
so donald trump went over to his little
buddy ben carson
and had ben carson approve that purchase
so that's donald trump or the trump
family essentially
right there making 33 million dollars
from selling a complex a government
subsidized complex
that he was only able to do because of
his position in government
so that's really concerning i guess the
the question is
was the approval out of bounds or was
the approval in bounds but trump was
able to grease the wheels
was the request officially made i is
i'll tell you straight up uh there was
an advertisement for
trump properties on a state department
website
that got like huge red flag and that get
pulled donald trump suggested using
trump doral in florida for what was the
g7 i think
and there was a huge backlash even among
conservatives saying you can't do it
he's like but we're going to give the
government a cheap rate and they're like
we don't care
donald trump used trump properties for
air force personnel who are like flying
to scotland
and then said yeah but we gave it to him
at cost and
there was still a big backlash even from
conservatives who are like dude
you're still maintaining your business
by doing this
so trump got reemed pretty hard for that
now joe biden
joe biden's son was flown on air force
two to china for a billion dollar
private equity deal
where his family was given a five
million dollar forgivable interest free
loan and when tony bob bilinski found
out they took the money we told not to
do it he came out and blew the whistle
and he and he said the bidens are
compromised or you've got the ukraine
barisma
deal where matt taibbi a liberal
formerly of rolling stone reported
there were at least a dozen or more
investigations for criminal activity
into burisma where joe biden's son was
working and biden personally flew out
after their pr company reached at the
state department saying why are you
investigating
stop this now joe biden goes out there
and says if you don't fire the
prosecutor you ain't getting a billion
dollars
no quid pro quo i can't i cannot i'm
sorry i can't i
any money did you not just say i said he
was flown in air force two
by joe biden to negotiate a private a
billion dollar private equity deal in
china
now i read about that and that's
definitely not a good look for hunter
byte and 100
why was why why was joe biden using
government property to fly his son for
private deals in china
uh whether they got a deal or not it was
probably corrupt
it was probably corrupt i think there's
corruption again there's corruption on
both sides here but if i'm
forced to choose between donald what's
the misinformation well the the
misinformation here i was referring to
the
there's a lot of misinformation about
the 1.5 million but i know you didn't
bring down
1.5 billion um which that was only like
a goal they were trying to make 1.5
billion in capital
um attempted murder crime and then you
said that
they uh got a five million dollar
forgivable interest free loan
i haven't that i actually haven't heard
about but joe biden did not get that
special prosecutor fired you're wrong
you're you're so
wrong no i'm not you're so out of your
depth bro did you see the
video of him uh talking about it i it's
my it's just
listen it's my understanding that this
prosecutor was fired for doing a poor
job and that you're wrong
did can we name the prosecutor i don't
know exactly
victor schokin can we factor the video
sure well when i i don't
want to play the video of joe biden
saying but uh i'll break it down for you
because matt taibbi is not a
conservative the uk
froze the assets of mykola zlachevsky
he's the guy who founded barisma so
you don't have any idea what you're
talking about right now zlatchevsky was
under criminal investigation
when joe biden intervened there were at
least a dozen investigations into him
and this company
hunter biden was put on the board for
seemingly no reason probably to garner
influence when asked about it
hunter biden was asked if you weren't
joe biden's son would you have gotten
this job he says
probably not so even it's his
acknowledgement that's why they brought
him on
we also have the emails where he's when
he's doing this chinese negotiations
they talk about the big guy and that was
confirmed by tony babinski i digress
victor shokun was the prosecutor who
signed a sworn affidavit
in court in ukraine that said he was
investigating active investigations and
joe biden
intervened and put pressure on him and
he had a meeting with the president
after the president was told we're not
going to get the billion dollars and he
said to him you're being fired
and that was it so when you have the pr
company and these emails are publicly
released you should probably read them
where they're saying why are we being
investigated the vice president's son is
on the board
and then what was like a couple months
later joe biden flies out there and gets
the prosecutor fired here's the best
part
if you're saying the prosecutor is doing
a bad job my question is how come
the new prosecutor who came in cleared
barisma of all wrong cleared zlatchevsky
of all wrongdoing
allowing him to return to ukraine after
he was under criminal investigation and
it's only after donald trump got in and
started pressing things he fled to
monaco
so if you don't know any but you can't
just come and say it's misinformation
because i've done
so much reporting on this more important
more about the more about whether joe
biden actually played a role in getting
the prosecutor fired oh okay let's play
the video
i i don't want to see the video i want
to actually see an article do you want
to hear joe biden say i got him fired
because he
because they wanted a billion dollars
and i held it over their head he
literally did say it
do you think it's odd that hunter biden
was getting paid tens of thousands of
dollars in a position that everyone knew
he shouldn't
be in he never had any experience the
charisma yeah
the board position yeah um i thought
that he took an unpaid job with that no
he got
paid tens of thousands of dollars and
yeah
and here's the thing is is kind of like
what i've already been saying is
i recognize that there is corruption on
both sides it was to my understanding
that joe biden didn't play a role
role in getting that prosecutor well but
if i'm wrong let's let's play the video
all right let's let's listen to the
video so no i said i'm not gonna or
we're not gonna give you the billion
dollars they said you have no authority
you're not the president the president
said i said call him
i said i'm telling you you're not
getting a billion dollars i said you're
not getting the billion i'm gonna be
leaving here and i think it was about
six hours i look i said i'm leaving in
six hours
if the prosecutor's not fired you're not
getting the money
well son of a [ __ ] got fired
and they put in place someone who was
solid
someone who was solid who cleared
zlatsky of all wrongdoing
and then after trump got in they
reopened investigations and he fled to
monaco
so it sounds like based on the fact that
the pr firm for barismo was reaching out
to state department
that joe biden admitted he used a
billion dollars in guaranteed loans
something he's not allowed to do
that's what they accused trump of doing
he doesn't have the authority to only
congress has the authority to do it joe
biden illegally
said you're not getting a billion
dollars unless a prosecutor gets fired
matt taibi you know who matt tybee is no
rolling stone liberal hates trump
wrote an article he said how about how
crazy it was
that if you actually did any amount of
basic journalism you found a dozen or
more
active criminal investigations in this
company in fact
i don't know uh there probably is if i
could just really quickly like i will
100
concede again that yes there is
corruption on both sides i hadn't seen
that video before so i will be 100
willing to look more into that yeah
that's the video that i was asking
specifically
yeah i'm glad that you played that for
me because i mean i'm always open to
learning new information
and some but also i've been wrong about
plenty of other things before too i'm
not afraid to acknowledge it yeah this
is in the news also today as the
department of justice
just announced that they're
investigating hunter biden specifically
with his burisma ties
and that's today that's today and
there's also let's find out and there's
also
new emails showing that there's close to
four hundred
thousand dollars that were unreported
income from
barisma when it comes to hunter biden so
it was
more than this is and this is there yes
yes and this is important to
to you know understand here on the
backdrop of the attorney general
resigning
today since of course william barr
actually hid
a lot of this information before this
election and also made sure that the
subpoenas
surrounding this particular
investigation weren't released
after the election now we're finding out
some of these subpoenas and this could
be one of the reasons why william barr
the attorney general who said he saw eps
the epstein tapes that were supposedly
deleted
resigned today sorry that's another side
topic that i just borrowed
but this is this is important news
because this broke today
and they're specifically looking at
burisma so this could this could blow up
in everyone's face very soon so let's
let's pull the story real quick it
literally goes
right back it goes right back to what we
were saying about the dominion voting
thing like
i've heard different information than
what i was just told now
but i would be more than happy to see an
investigation into this
i don't want our politicians to be
corrupt unfortunately they both are i
mean
even like um uh jared kushner like uh
i think it was a um i was in saudi
arabia yes he negotiated better weapons
deals for saudi arabia
what i'm talking about i'm talking about
um another uh radical islamic
country i can't remember no it was qatar
um
and they said that jared kushner
allegedly they said that jared kushner
was in
his pocket so i think that there's a lot
of corruption
on both sides and i think that if
anything like
i didn't vote for biden because i liked
him okay not at all i don't i don't like
biden
but i was kind of stuck between biden or
trump and i felt like biden in this
instance was a little bit of a better
option
especially as just as a dad there were a
lot of things i was seeing with what
trump was saying that
i just couldn't align with i mean i know
we talked about the flag burning thing
but
even trump's like uh 1776 commission
um with like trying to explicitly
teach children a a biased
pro-american viewpoint like my
daughter's almost two
and i don't want to think about it but i
know she's going off to school soon
right
i don't want her going and being taught
like a brainwashed
like the 16 19 project like they're
teaching right now homeschooler well
hold on hold on
is the six and this is something i want
to know is the 1619 project being taught
in schools
yes is it a white spot is it a
curriculum it is
really because that is not what i saw
when i read that when i looked whoa
when did you hear the wind blowing yes
that was crazy awesome was that outside
yeah what what's going on tonight dark
winter wow
the dark winter is coming uh 1619
project and critical race theory
critical race theory more importantly is
being taught as basic curriculum across
the country
if i'm if i'm not mistaken i believe
that the 1619 project although
historically inaccurate and very stupid
uh i i think that it's being taught in
maybe some select schools but it's not
like a national curriculum right
i'm pretty sure it it well maybe new
york times like
maybe you can say yeah yeah and schools
are teaching it like crazy because these
teachers they they hold this idea that's
that's
like crazy where where is it happening
here where is the list
well you know i followed james lindsay
for this stuff to be honest i don't know
where the next
i actually was unaware that the 1619
project was being taught
widespread what is the gist of it the
16-19
it's it's a historically and accurate
account
of basically america's founding and they
argue that america was founded on
um like i don't even fully understand it
either because i just know it's stupid
and
from education next educators around the
country are indeed teaching the 1619
project
what precisely students and other
interested observers are learning is
another question
the 1619 project is certainly
educational or at least instructive but
not the uh not
only in the ways it was intended and
they going to explain what it is in the
classroom
uh random house children book children's
books announced plans to publish four 16
19 projects
books for young readers one young adult
et cetera et cetera so yes
yeah yeah i mean so that that would
definitely be a problem but would it be
better that they learned like
a very patriotic pro-america or a very
anti-america
it would be better for them to learn a
the truth about america and not have a
truth the true historically accurate
account of how america got started right
based on which which art like which uh
author or which literature
i i don't know do you know well so an
example would be some might tell you
uh notably like the new york times that
america truly started in 1619
right that's even the author of the 16th
or even one of the people on 1619
acknowledged that it wasn't really
historically accurate
yeah it's funny because only like way
later after like they started getting
attacked relentlessly nonstop but they
won pulitzers for it so
this is this is just my problem though
is see this is
donald trump trying to combat this 1619
project by doing something that i would
argue is just as bad
i don't want a biased so so what was
this curriculum that he was going to
teach
he was going to teach a pro-patriotic
which would be explicitly biased in
favor of america
that kind of a curriculum like that's
brainwashing also right
yeah we want to teach kids the truth and
listen
here's something else i promise you i
know this sounds like it's unrelated but
it is
uh one of the things i talk about a lot
on my channel is the fat acceptance
movement which are the
the body positivity people the people
that are really fat that claim that oh
just who cares about health let's just
love your body
i've always argued that if you love your
body you would work to change your body
and work to improve it
and i think the exact same thing goes
for the country i as a dad like i want
this country
to be better i want this country to be
better for my kids and
i don't think that you can push for
genuine and
accurate change if you have a
brainwashed
interpretation of america and that you
like star wars that goes for the 1619
project as well
not really you don't you know like star
wars not really did you watch the
original
yeah what do you think that with like
luke skywalker and you know tattooing
and the death star
of course what do you think about it
yeah it's all right
who do you think uh do you like luke
skywalker in the jedi
yeah sure yeah you think like you think
what he did was cool
i haven't watched that movie in a really
long time and admittedly i have not
researched on my star wars before coming
up
but like you know han solo luke
skywalker you know they were cool right
they were
they were heroes yeah yeah do you think
it's cool that some scraggly religious
zealots from a desert planet took a
cargo ship and blew up a military base
that's star wars yes sir and that's and
that's not like
that point is made by the left when they
say people watch star wars and don't
understand why they're cheering for it
they're cheering for a religious faction
from a desert planet taking a
cargo ship and fighter and rebel fighter
pilots and then blowing up a military
base
it's actually clerks i think you know
with the you know was it the kevin smith
film made a really good point
there were contractors and janitors and
like regular people just working on this
base had no idea what's going on
yeah they all got killed according to
the guy in clerks they people that are
contractors have
political bias they choose to work
exactly so you choose to work on a
military base so when al qaeda blows it
up that's your own fault
the point is you talk about being pro
you know trump's
pro-america view of the world and it's
like sure you could argue that the
founding fathers were insurrectionist
terrorists
who were just greedy slave owners and
wanted to wanted to reject the crown
because the crown wanted its cut
and and and furthermore the british were
defending the seas for the american
colonies the
ingrates were angry over a t tax because
they don't want to pay their
fair share well i it's kind of
ridiculous right yeah of course and and
i'm not saying that that's the
alternative to donald trump's approach
what i'm arguing for is a just a
historically accurate
interview maybe that's what would have
happened of the hit of history well
that's not that's
and if that was how it was told that
wouldn't be historically accurate well
that's based on you know people's
interpretation because you could
interpret history in many different ways
but
i agree with your point that our kind of
higher learning institutions are in
our school institutions are corrupted
but i don't think it's because of trump
i think they're they've been like that
for a very long time especially since
their institution
under the rockefeller policies that
wanted to make good factory workers
and that's essentially what kind of
school is in our modern day and age
so there's a couple things that come up
to mind when you're talking about this
one interesting one was the recent
decision by cornell university
that recently decided that they're going
to be making the vaccine
mandatory the coven 19 va covet 19
uh vaccine mandatory but only for white
students
i was wondering yeah is that actually a
true story yes
yes cornell vaccine and right here only
applies to white students
and the best part is wait wait hold on
hold on there's one more two in oregon
they're doing grants for kova that only
go to black businesses so it's like
yeah so when you have when you have
institutions like that that are hired by
you know the the state can i find a
little more context on that cornell i
could send you the article
if you there's also another incident
that i would love to get your kind of
feedback on
in new york city we have the school
superintendent literally arguing and
trying to make it a mandate
that if there's a poor white kid and a
middle class or rich
black kid that school resources should
predominantly go to the black kid right
not to the poor white
we got it from the college fix cornell
vaccine mandate only applies to white
students saying
quote we recognize that due to
long-standing systemic racism and health
inequities in this country
individuals from some marginalized
communities may have concerns about
needing to agree to such requirements
for example
historically the bodies of the black
indigenous and people of uh and
people of color have been mistreated and
used by people in power sometimes for
profit or medical gain
it is understandable that the current
compact requirement may feel suspect or
even exploitative to some bypoc members
of the cornell community
additionally recent acts of violence
against black people by law enforcement
may contribute to feelings of distrust
or powerlessness while the university
strongly recommends that non-white
students comply voluntarily because
long-standing social inequity
inequalities and health disparities have
resulted in covet 19
disproportionately affecting bypoc
individuals they will be granted an
exemption if they cite their racial
identity i mean that's
that's definitely very bold that's
definitely like some [ __ ] right
there
i think what they're doing is like
because systemic racism for example is
100 a real thing but that is probably
the dumbest
most idiotic way imaginable all of what
it is
but it's not though because you have
like you do have your maybe a good
policy
you have your what do you mean like name
if that's an example of like doing it
wrong
what's an example of rectifying systemic
racism correctly
sure so in these for example uh majority
black communities where they are
have much more rates of poverty and
higher rates of crime uh
obviously the reason for the high crime
rate is because of poverty
so i would uh like i'm not a policy
maker but i would like to see
more investment into those areas because
if we were for example able to
open up better businesses give people
more jobs
hire people that's what step one uh
that's gentrification
you're talking about sending in the
white upper class to black neighborhoods
to gentrify the neighborhood
to price them out you're a racist no no
no i'm not arguing for that at all no
i'm not that
then what i'm arguing for is investing
in that contract what money where is it
where does the money come from it might
be this is called gentrification
when the situation is when the city when
white people move in and then rent
prices go up
that's that's a simplification
gentrification if they come in and they
start putting all this money into
buildings
and infrastructure and then the property
values are skyrocketing these black
families are going to get priced out
taxed out and they're getting kicked out
that's not what i want to happen what i
want to see happen is
more business investments specific so
let me ask you a question
if more businesses start popping up in
these neighborhoods right
will property value go up you tell me
well the answer is yes of course more
more business means more taxes means
more commerce more tax revenue better
streets better buildings
better repairs and tax tax goes up right
right what do you think happens to these
poor black families who now can't pay
the higher tax rates because their
property value went up well that's the
problem right there is see i don't want
these big companies to just come in
start opening up and then
raising the prices what i want is to see
a proper investment into this area
where not only is it just people coming
along investment from who
to what listen listen listen you
understand what you're saying is
extremely racist
you're promoting the eviction of black
families prices no no no what you're
doing is you're trying to use this like
liberal hypocrisy thing on me i know
i know no no no no no what i'm telling
you is you what you're advocating for
by the left is considered wrong i don't
care what the left thinks
i'm not a leftist but i'm not supposed
to work so i stand by
my positions that's what i do when i
when i'm telling you that you're
proposing a policy to end systemic
racism you're you're not that's not
my policy that's what we want you to do
so listen another option would be we
need to stop funding schools with the
taxes collected in that neighborhood
obviously because that creates a vicious
cycle where then you have poor people
going to [ __ ] schools and it
repeats forever that's another example
of what we can do to fix it
but again i'm not a policy maker and i
recognize that what i've said about
investing in those areas is a rather
uh surface level and simplified version
of what i think could help
for me i'm more interested in talking to
people about systemic racism right now
because we first have to acknowledge
that the problem even exists
before we can go about fixing the
problem and how would you define
systemic racism
well i define systemic racism a little
differently than i think a lot of people
would for me
uh systemic racism would be it's
oftentimes like you can see it in
history and then you can see it today
still so you can see where that racist
policy was created
how it affected blacks and how it's
still affecting them today
or any other minority group or any other
minority group sure like systemic racism
majority majority major league majorly
majorly affects like black people for
the most part but yeah they're
other people can be victims of systemic
racism too does it
does it predominantly affect black
families or black people yeah and that's
because
and that's because a lot of the reasons
that black people are in the position
they are today is of course because of
historical racist policies from america
like red lining is a perfect example
and blockbusting yeah yeah i mean
there's there's plenty of them even the
war on drugs right which
i mean joe biden further exacerbated
with the crime bill like
there's plenty of cia luke you know
about cia and crack right yes oh yeah
yeah there was also the um the the crack
versus cocaine thing
let me tell you uh the modern left right
now doesn't understand what systemic
racism is
and neither does the right they think
systemic means institutionalized
and so it's really hard to have a
conversation with people about systemic
racism
because they immediately think
institutionalized right so their
response immediately is like well then
tell me about an institution that's like
no
no i'm talking about systemic right and
they say well you mean historical i'm
like yes that's what systemic meant the
system
created a problem it's it's we're not
talking about the institution of
policing or hospitals or schools we're
talking about
the easiest example i give to people is
uh because i did a documentary on this
uh pruitt igo uh commun public housing
in st
louis the st louis county racial housing
covenants in the suburbs
most people don't realize that st louis
isn't one city when people say st
louis they're referring to like 90
different cities all of these little
tiny cities that surround it going
westward
that were formed because people white
people were fleeing the inner city due
to increasing poverty and crime
and because of racism they created new
townships and then immediately enacted
racial covenants
so these are laws that are no longer
legal but it basically created a system
that created a two-tier
like oversimplifying things for sure but
you basically create two tracks where
one is doing well and one is doing
poorly
you get rid of the laws that made this
problem happen like redlining or
blockbusting
and now we're dealing with the
generational after effects of why these
people
are in in poverty why there's crime in
their areas the problem is
we're now at a point now where after
we've gotten rid of the racist racist
laws
we had racist law we had racial
covenants
and now we have the modern left
advocating for bringing back
racial law and i'm like well that's the
stupidest thing you've ever heard
uh like talking about in policies
directed towards different races or
affirmative action like policies
you're just talking about creating more
laws like look at this way if you went
back in time
and and said we're gonna create a law
for white people to protect them then
people would argue but it's just a
positive thing it doesn't hurt them it's
it's you know
well no it's creating a disproportionate
effect which will result in one you know
group of people doing better than the
other which will lead to poverty crime
and other detriments because you're
essentially
you know you can make the argument but
ultimately of a two-track system create
systemic racism
today they're saying basically the same
thing and if you look at like ibrahim x
kennedy his argument
is that we need more discrimination
that's what we need more discrimination
and that's like okay he would have fit
in really really well
with the people in the 50s who wanted
separate but equal rights that's
basically what he's advocating for
more he says the solution to past
discrimination
is present discrimination or i can't
remember the exact quote but
it was something like that it passed
present discrimination a lot towards
white people
no to uh towards everybody oh like he
just wants to continue being yeah so so
his idea is
like you know i'm trying to steal man's
argument that if you have people who are
disproportionately affected by past
you know historical precedent and laws
then we need to
target different communities based on
race and discriminate positively or
negatively
meaning negative towards one group
that's doing too well like asians for
instance and positive towards the
latinos who aren't doing as well
yes yeah i would disagree with that
entirely i don't think that we should be
stifling one to try to bring them down i
think what we should try to be doing is
helping the communities that are where
they are today because of american
policies in the history
of the past get to where everyone else
is i don't i've
never agreed with this idea of tearing
one down to try to bring one
up kind of crap i know that there's a
lot of like lib [ __ ] and people that
advocate for crap like that um but no i
would never be
in favor of anything well there's
different issues to really kind of
consider here because if you're going to
if you're going to try to help people
who are hurt historically
you know what about the polish people
who are subjugated by the nazis and then
the ussr like
well there's there's also i mean we can
go about like
i think there are going to be different
ways that we can address different kind
of historical
uh like oppressions but the main reason
that i think it's so important that we
focus
on black people in america right now is
because this is a really prevalent
example of where a
huge group of people are still being
greatly disproportionately affected by
policies that although are no longer
like on the books
the results of that poli those policies
still exist right
so the problem now is having done away
with those laws
we've and and with uh the passing of
things like loving v virginia
we've now created not just one community
it's not just the black community
anymore
it is the impo the you know poor
neighborhoods
and i'm not saying you know not all
black neighborhoods are poor if you look
at where obama was you know in hyde park
it's it's it's very well off
right so targeting it based on race is a
mistake you don't like we don't want to
you don't think the obama family needs
help
certainly not they're some of the
smartest and most accomplished people in
the world
well i do think i so singling out race
would be you know
well i mean obviously it's not to say
that all black people are living in
poverty and i wouldn't say that
to fix systemic racism we have so the
answer is
class-based resolutions well i would
argue that the reason see the reason
that black people are in poverty
is because specifically because they are
black
because they were discriminated against
because of that so
that's a bold statement that was
extremely
dangerous black people are black people
were historically discriminated against
and that's why they are today that's
what we were just agreeing on i feel
like i've had more than enough
uh guests on this show who would
completely disagree with you and are
literally black
see the problem i don't care what i mean
that's identity politics i'm not
concerned about what the
people think i i'm more you're not
concerned with what black people think
there's a white
guy saying you know what's right for
their community and you don't hear what
they know
no not at all what i'm saying that
they're all poor
did i did i say that all black people
were poor did i say that black
all black people it was very generalized
did i did i say that all black people
reported no you said that they're poor
the sole reason they're poor is because
they're black no
oh good one tim isn't that what you said
no i said they are they are
discriminated against for being black so
it is bit it's based on race because
they were discriminated against in the
past
because of their race right obviously
they're not poor because they're black
they're poor because
that black people are disproportionately
poor because black people were
discriminated against in the past
because of their race that's wrong you
know why
why because what about immigrants who
came here like 10 years ago
that's entirely different actually are
you talking about um nigerians
haitians i mean i i'm not too familiar
with haitians but i know nigerians for
example are cited a lot of the times as
an example of
uh like how can systemic racism exist
and a lot
i agree stomach racism exists i just
think that we shouldn't
use race as the factor because you've
got multi generations
of families that have now existed
outside of the confines of racial
covenants and racial laws
you have immigrants for generations who
have come in and faced completely
different circumstances
sure and if individuals are racist
there's no
real hard solution for that because you
know people still
have some level of freedom to associate
now i'm actually fairly liberal on a lot
of issues particularly like
i think if you're operating a business
in public you have to serve the public
within reason so like i actually agree
that
you know we should have laws saying you
want to run a bakery and someone comes
in and says i require service you give
it to him
now the specific example with the baker
in colorado was that he wouldn't write a
message it's very different that that i
actually think he shouldn't have to do
but if i own a own a shop you shouldn't
be able to say this particular group is
barred from entry that's wrong
sure yeah so if if we're dealing with a
way to solve systemic racism
which exists it's actually impossible to
solve by using racial law or
saying we're going to give money to a
community based on their race
because you'll get you'll end up giving
a haitian immigrant you know i'm sure
and i'm not in the same circumstances no
no no no
i think that this is a bit of a
misrepresentation and again i understand
that i i
i'm not a policy maker here so but
uh no i'm not saying we just go give
money to black communities i'm saying we
would invest in yes in those poor
communities that
oftentimes unfortunately tend to be
black as well
and the reason for that is because of
historical inequality
so i'm not saying that racial laws are
the solution but i'm saying that
acknowledging that black people are
where they are today
largely because they were discriminated
against because of their race that's
just the fact of the matter
it was they got a bunch of the slaves
that basically came from they're
discriminated against because they were
like the
the descendants of slaves and didn't
have any money coming out there was no
historical wealth
why when we look at when we look at
american history we see a history of a
lot of immigrants of a lot of
discrimination
a lot of different groups are
discriminated against but i particularly
wanted to get your point on the new york
city
school superintendent saying when their
school when their school resources it
shouldn't go to the poor white kid
it should go to the middle class and
even upper class black kid
yeah i mean that's dumb okay that's very
dumb obviously i mean yeah we're talking
about
this is like this is such a huge problem
that the left does all the time which is
where we
are criticizing systems and then they
apply or then they apply that to an
individual
which is really really a problem i mean
white privilege is like a perfect
example like
you can talk about on a statistical
level white people
might have some level of privilege over
other groups
but if you then go up to one single
white guy and be like screw-offs
privileged white boy
that's like a problem because it's
you're supposed to be
compassionate towards people and
ruthless towards systems right that's uh
kind of like
what i like to do the bigger problem i
think with like the concept of white
privilege is that it's
actually majority privilege you know
like if you you can't even
like you personally would not succeed or
survive at all in east asia
oh sure i mean and i do think that yeah
it is partially majority privilege first
it's like
whichever whichever group tends to have
more access and more wealth and control
of more systems
people tend to favor so so i'm just
gonna be straight up with people
this is a fact i teach you this and
interact with other groups and people
who look differently
then there's going to be a bias and it's
going to be harder for that person to
succeed in that in that environment
and especially if they're like uh like a
white person going to east asia like
you can't even own property in some of
these countries yeah that's terrible
yeah
well i don't know if it's terrible i
mean you tell them that they'll tell you
to get to go away and you can't do
anything about it you know what i mean
yeah i mean
what's causing that yeah it's not my rv
but another thing but i have to say one
of my favorite things is is seeing
manual labor low-paying job people being
lectured by hollywood billionaires about
their privilege
i think that's also another phase here
that people need to realize there's a
lot of establishment
kind of corporatist language kind of
pushed in this that
as you could say is very virtual
signaling cringy
it's very cringy and i'm happy you could
at least admit that and we could have an
honest dialogue and conversation
you gotta remember i used to be like the
wrecked feminist guy i'm not here to
like
[ __ ] shield yeah yeah you know i
appreciate the conversation because we
could understand where you're where
you're coming from and we should
understand your point of view and
perspective and
and it's not just my party's always
right
you know you're willing to kind of not
at all that's i would 100 i would
concede that easily
yeah yeah and i think that's critically
important and that's something that's
especially missing in today's day and
age of dialogue which is all
dominated by it's even better than you
exactly and you know that's another big
thing that i was
that as i kind of found myself sort of
going away from the right that i really
discovered is um how harmful
labels seem to be also i mean this idea
that like oh i don't know if i can
support this idea because that's a
liberal idea or that's a right-wing idea
i'm so sick and tired of that for now
like i just like to look at ideas that i
support or that i don't support and why
i support them or why i don't
and go with it that way i'm not
concerned if it's generally a liberal
thing or a right-wing thing and i think
that that's i think that sort of
like looking past labels is an important
step in
trying to find an agreement a privilege
first of all i would disagree with
telling a poor white person they have
white privilege to begin with well i
would say that's a very kind of
generalized
kind of statement and it all depends on
the circumstance all depends on the
situation
all depends also on the location that
you're in so
sure you know that i mean a good example
would be that there was a um um
a study done several years ago now where
they i'm sure you've all heard of this
study actually where they sent out a
bunch of
job applications um some of them had
like
cliche white sounding names and then
others had black sounding names
they had the identical qualifications
okay the
the uh um the black names
were far more likely to not get a call
back compared to the white names
so i think that's an example where maybe
it's easier sometimes for white people
to get a job simply because i have a
standard white name maybe that is
majority privilege maybe you can call it
a majority privilege
i mean but that's still there's laws in
california where your board members have
to be a specific
color ruling the other way there's a lot
of quotas and government agencies that
mandate you have a specific person of
this ethnicity or this
ideology or sex inside of your your
business
so i mean that particular study i'm not
aware of i would like to look into it
and study it more
but uh there's also the opposite
happening which needs to be called out
i don't like quotas either i mean i
think that's a pretty generally bad idea
to try and what you do is you don't get
genuine push for diversity or genuine
people that like appreciate having a
diverse workplace instead you get people
that are doing it just because they have
to
and it hurts everyone in the long run it
hurts everyone in the long run and also
if i could just add really quickly like
there have also been studies that found
that diversity
does benefit the workforce and that when
there's diversity in the workplace
like productivity is better creativity
is better efficiency is better all that
so i agree that diversity makes the
workplace better but i think when you're
forcing that
under like a quota then yeah you kind of
fall back into that cringy corporate
defined diversity um i mean
it would really depend i guess on on the
context it could be
racial diversity uh it could be um
diversity between like men and women i
guess
um i know that there are there were some
kind of was it the grammys
quota or something the the general idea
is that diversity of opinion
will lead to better success because
you're getting a wide range of options
and then you work through to find the
best one what's happened is that
the left is kind of right when they say
diversity you know
strength it's like yeah but when your
idea of diversity is ideological
homogeneity
and people just look different that's
not actually diversity
the original idea was that if you have
someone from india and someone from the
u.s collaborating on a project
they're going to have wildly different
perspectives which can actually result
in finding a solution
a singular ideological group could not
discover instead
of you know actually saying we want
people of varying of thoughts and
opinions and backgrounds to come
together they're saying
so long as you all completely agree
politically
and look different we've accomplished
diversity which of course is not
you'll end up with a bunch of people who
can't actually solve any problems
because they'll think the same thing
right and i i mean that's obviously
that's that's obviously cringe worthy
i'm all for diversity of thought um as
well as i'm all for
diversity i mean you'll hear a lot of
conservatives like criticize
multiculturalism for example that's a
pretty common
buzzword i hear from a lot of people on
the right but multiculturalism and
diversity ultimately has
only gone to better our country
ultimately define multiculturalism
uh multiple different cultures
so like which cultures though
i i just i know that generally speaking
like right now we are a multicultural
country
because we have plenty of different
cultures in our country um
and like we're the world superpower we
have subcultures
but you know the problem right now is
that there's actually there's there's
two
dominant cultures and it's resulting in
people killing each other in the streets
what do you mean well like the like
michael reinel shooting you know aaron
danielson twice in the chest it's a
cultural difference
so when when conservatives say
multiculturalism they're referring to
two you know more than one culture com
you know existing coexisting next to
each other without an overarching parent
culture guiding the actions of all the
individuals within
so uh so leftists usually think
multiculturalism works america is a good
example
if you're talking about say like
ukrainian village in chicago
little italy chinatown and things like
that
what you're saying is that all of these
different communities have agreed to
abide by american
americans cultures and norms oh no when
did i say that
i'm i'm saying you like the rhetorical
you like when when the left argues for
multiculturalism
they're explaining that you've got
america as this big umbrella and a bunch
of smaller cultures
underneath it so if you come as it's
like a
someone from china comes to the u.s and
opens a restaurant and brings their
family
they abide by american laws and american
customs and free speech and courts and
all that all those roles that don't
exist in china it's one of the reasons
many people want to come here
what the right is saying is that if you
have leftists socialists communists
sjw critical race theory and you have it
next to a different culture which is
libertarianism individualism
etc they clash they fight they rip each
other apart
in that sense multiculturalism doesn't
work in the sense
of having a bunch of different immigrant
communities all abiding by american law
norms multiculturalism does work depends
on how you define it
yeah but i think the general idea of
multiculturalism have taken if you take
the word at face
that made you kind of switch over yeah i
mean there was definite it was
definitely not like one thing
um not at all it was a very long process
actually and
um it's funny because i know you had
vosh on here a couple couple weeks ago
but um
he's actually a big part of this story
so um what happened was
you know after i uh found out that my
then girlfriend was
pregnant i went through a lot of
personal issues and thought that i had
made some mistakes here and there
long story short i turned out to be
completely wrong about my initial
approach to like how i was handling this
and like
sorry we're just dealing with uh just
pull it out
it just i was i was i thought this was
like something like breaking up with my
then girlfriend at the time was
something that i
really did feel strongly about and i
thought it was the right decision after
doing a lot of like thought into it
and this was something that i was really
really serious about and believed really
strongly and then it turned out to be
catastrophically totally wrong and so i
think that kind of set in motion this
sort of subconscious like
if i was so wrong about something i
thought i was so right about is there
anything else like this in my life
and it was around this time of like a
lot of contemplating right
when i was challenged to a debate by
vosh none other than
than vosh right he uh and you know we we
had a long debate and
obviously i think he beat me um and
he particularly provided some pretty
good points on lgbt issues which i know
we're not really going to talk about
that today but
since that was something that i was so
notorious and like being against
um and that kind of further set in
motion i was like wow now
not only am i kind of contemplating my
ideas but now i'm being challenged and
seeing a lot of data that seems like
it's
uh pushing back against what i
originally thought about some of these
subjects
so from there i just went on to do my
own research and kind of went through it
and it wasn't until
april of this year that i actually
announced i'd left the right so
a lot of people will say oh hunter lost
one debate with a fat communist and then
became a liberal
that's not what happened so let's make
sure it's
you know earlier you talked about the
importance of the traditional family
that seems also in line with a lot of
things that are happening in our society
that's breaking down because if you look
at the traditional family you could see
it in decline
a lot of people kind of point to it for
a lot of the problems in our society do
you also see it
the same way or well what do you or why
do you have such a
you know strong value and strong opinion
strong opinion on traditional families
yeah i mean i think that if you're
raising children traditional families or
the nuclear family meaning two parents
raising the kid
i think that that is undisputed that
that's the best environment for the
child
so for me i support traditional
households when you're raising kids
because just because that
is proven to be the best thing for the
child right now
um but i wouldn't support traditional
like i
i'm fine with people living their lives
however they want i'm
i'm all about traditional family for
myself and i think that has a lot of
benefits for raising kids but i don't
think that that should be prescribed on
anyone else
so if the traditional family is in like
decline or not
i'm not as concerned about that because
i like to assume now i don't i would
want to know why
it's declining right but i like to
assume that it's probably because of
people choosing to either pursue
different career paths or
maybe more you know more people are able
to be gay or be bisexual or
who knows like i think there's a lot of
different reasons there that's not
particularly a concern of mine though
like i'm
as long as the reason behind it is good
i don't really have a problem with that
so what do you uh what do you read for
news
all over i just i read all over it i i
don't have like one
source that i go to i may usually what
will happen right is i'll see something
on twitter and i'm like i don't know
about that and then i
go and look into it from there and then
you know or it's it's just if it's a
subject that i'm interested in i'll
research it on and read from different
sources um
so i don't it's the it's the biggest
determinating factor in your political
alliance is what you read for news
really the left overwhelmingly trusts
mainstream news organizations
even though they're caught endlessly
lying and exaggerating and
you know putting out garbage and the
right completely distrusts them
so the right tends to go to either right
right leaning outlets or
often to their own detriment like fringe
outlets that often have
bunk information as well so that's like
the two two sides of one coin right
it's like different ways to get a bad
news diet right exactly you know so it's
like
but the the interesting thing is there's
there's a
one study often said all the time it's
on my twitter somewhere the
liberals or the left i hate calling them
liberals because they're not liberal
but the left gets 95 of their news from
mainstream or left biased sources
moderates get 60
from left by sources and 30 from right
by sources the right it's inverted 60
right 30 left so conservatives know what
the left is thinking the left doesn't
know what the right is thinking
as evidenced my favorite example is when
the hashtag proudboys was
taken over by the left and it was a
bunch of photos of
you know gay men kissing and then they
were like take that proud boys you know
calling them homophobes and stuff
and then people started posting the
photo of gavin mcinnis the founder of
the proud boys making out with milo
yiannopoulos like i don't think you guys
know
anything about this group and they
clearly didn't so they're all doing
these clap-back snapbacks thinking they
they're they're owning the cons i don't
really think that no
idea or in certain an item up somewhere
which we will mention on this
show but another thing to really watch
out if you're getting your news from you
from like social media is the echo
chambers that are naturally created
there by the algorithms
that literally give you what you want to
read to keep you on their platform
yeah absolutely and i don't i do not get
my news for social media i recognize
did you watch on that netflix
documentary a little while back on
social dilemma the social dilemma yeah i
didn't know yeah it talks about how the
algorithms on the social media platforms
are
designed to keep on feeding you the
stuff that you're already like yeah
so yeah you do get into an echo chamber
so i don't get my news from social media
what i mean is
if i see something on social media i
never take it at face value
what i usually like to do to form my
opinion on something is i like to read
about it from
multiple different sources and i would
prefer actually to read a
far left bias source a far right bias
source and then
hopefully somewhere a little more in the
middle in the neutral
so i mean that's obviously
oversimplifying it yeah absolutely
well considering the power is going out
i think we're having a really great
conversation
so i want to keep going but uh let's
jump over to super chats and then we'll
just you know carry on from there
because we gotta
we have a lot uh unfortunately due to
the power outages we lost the first hour
of super chats
well it lost the lo that we lost the
first 40 minutes kind of a
that is a bummer yep
should i read this should i read the
really mean ones or should i just try
and keep things constructed no
there's a lot of one direction saying no
don't read them
[Laughter]
they're all mean towards you they're all
mean some of them are okay but that's
that's the point like you know
all right go ahead hit me up i can
handle that monolithic ethos says hunter
is afraid to debate
uh debate actual justice warrior
see i don't know if it's like it's gonna
spark drama or something no no no no
it's
it's fine don't don't worry about that
we can go to the next one
you know what i'll tell you that's this
one dude who has like this like small
little following that's made like
10 plus videos on me he's like yeah no
he's like
it's so creepy and annoying and then and
he's also been
caught misrepresenting data multiple
different times so i told him this i
said yeah i'm not really interested in
debating you and you're super slippery
and i've seen you lie about data
multiple times
and of course now you know it's actually
because i'm too afraid so
continue positive gerald says this kid
gone learned today
perhaps perhaps none you beeswax says
america first is inevitable
okay let's see john schwalb says hunter
has no idea how the adoption system is
built
the kids waiting for adoption are
handled by the state babies given to
adoption agency have couples wait for a
year till the baby becomes available
you know i've i've read a bit about that
like it's really hard it's like a long
wait times and stuff like that yeah it's
it's really challenging to adopt but i
don't see how that's an argument against
gay people having the right to adopt
right i think we gotta get as many of
these you know kids without parents to
parents yeah yeah i mean yeah it's such
a process that's why so many people go
to russia and china to adopt their
children
which is a lot easier and quicker than
going through the process in the united
states which is a problem
in and of itself so i'm gonna i'm gonna
read this next super chat but i wanna
say first and foremost
uh we we we were discussing some things
before the show
and i have i i don't care about people's
opinions if you tell me that you feel
you know
we should do this thing this way i'll
tell you why i disagree or whatever
but i can't tell you you can't tell
someone their opinion is wrong
but dane miller says this dude left left
the right and became extremely
misinformed
thank you tim for showing him the way
been watching for a long time now keep
up the good work
here's my first donation merry christmas
so i think that
there's one moment we've had where i
think you were misinformed that's the
hunter biden stuff in barisma
and that's and and and if you didn't
know and you know that's fine
my opinion on whether or not joe biden
is a bad person is my opinion the facts
are he did these things my conclusion is
is you know after the fact sure
all right let's see tom says tim did you
hear about the 1.95 million chinese
communist party members embedded with
western governments or corporations that
got exposed the other day
i did hear about that and i'm sort of
waiting on it because
two things have you noticed the u.s
media kind of not reporting on it yeah
yeah the british and australian press
are going crazy with this
i covered this in my video this is
amazing i mean we're talking about
thousands of communist chinese party
members infiltrating
institutions of influence all over the
world we're talking about individuals
being a part of making the vaccine 123
communist chinese party me party members
were on
this list that helped make the kovid 19
vaccine and again when we look at china
and their coronavirus records there's a
lot to worry about here
but when it comes to intellectual
property being stolen when it comes to
even these br these chinese agents
working inside of the british
consulate we're talking about huge
implications
that are extremely vast i'm gonna blow
your mind right now
one of these chinese communist agents
was elected president
i'm kidding yeah i don't think we have
that we have
joe biden come on that was the joke
computer is going to shut off this thing
can only handle a few minutes of
downtime
we have like a 10 minute buffer before
it shuts off pretty impressive
we're still live though this time
because i switched to the satellite
internet
so we're still streaming even though the
power cut out you know we're going to
have to do
because this is a new thing but it is
the wind was so loud we heard it in here
people are mentioning in super chat
the wind is probably causing surges
which is resulting in outages so yeah
welcome to living in the mountains yep
so uh
yeah you voted for uh communist chinese
uh joe biden you must be glad that i'm
just kidding
yeah yeah of course let's see jr says
you made a really good point tim i own a
small corporation i have six employees
plus myself i pay them between 10 and 15
an hour i made 50k last year
yeah that was uh uh that's that's the
story i literally went to an accountant
and i was like what do you think about
this house is gonna impact you and the
guy was a democrat he was like
he's voted for democrat he's new jersey
votes for democrats all the time and he
was like they just don't know what
they're doing when they raise wages
it's a shock to the system like punching
them in the gut
we want wages to go up but it feels like
a seven-year-old solution you know what
i mean like you're sitting there
and you're hanging out with your friend
like your friends and you're all
drinking your beers and
you're talking about the economy and
your kid walks up and he's seven years
old
and then your kid stops and he's
listening and you say you know one of
the problems we have is we need more
buying power for the for the working
class in the lower class
but if they're only making 10 bucks an
hour you know we need to figure out how
to get those wages up and he goes
the government should just make it so
that you have to you have to pay them
more
and you're like okay you can't just say
that like the money doesn't exist
if a small business doesn't have the
money to pay people they can't just do
it
but if the government says it then they
have to pay it it's like okay dude you
needed to sit down we did
i think there are benefits to increasing
the minimum wage as i mentioned earlier
it means that if everyone in the u.s is
getting paid the same they can buy
foreign goods because the rate the labor
in other countries hasn't changed
and if say like the minimum wage
increases in a big city
it's easier for the people in the big
city to buy goods that are produced in
lower uh cost of living areas so there's
that's one benefit to a national minimum
wage increase the problem is
it has to be done in such a way that it
doesn't just shock the system right
and result in businesses shutting down
which is i think what they will probably
end up doing well i think there's a
reason the
super powerful corporations are always
calling for more taxes and regulations
it's because it's going to help them out
in the long run
let's see freestyle says tim pool china
is not to be a part of the tpp check
what tpp is about well the tpp doesn't
exist anymore it was crushed and china
was not a part of it
but the new trade agreement in the
pacific does include china no
the new trade agreement doesn't include
china doesn't know are you sure yeah
cause we did a segment on this before
i'm pretty sure no they're not involved
i'll look it up the one with like canada
and these other countries yeah well
that's good news i guess
well there you go um maybe that's what
referring to the new deal
the new trade agreement well there's
probably going to be a lot of tariffs
there's going to be probably
less of a trade war between china and
the united states would abide in
presidency and i think we're going to
see that
as we heard from d dongsheng it is
tremendous good news that trump
lost wink wink as the audience laughs
because uh
they're the ones who helped hunter biden
become as wealthy as he is the one that
the one that got created it's called the
comprehensive and progressive agreement
for trans-pacific partnership this is
the new one the new one
china's nbp 1-1 or tpp11 no no not china
it's australia
canada chile japan malaysia mexico new
zealand peru singapore and vietnam
mute met maker says i remember watching
hunter's channel back in 2017 and it
scratched my quote lib gets owned with
facts and logic itch
now that i'm a bit older like him 24 i
find myself caring less about social
issues
i just want the government off my porch
excuse me that's where you go
yeah i mean i care about social issues
but i also don't want the government
involved so
gone fall says i really feel like hunter
is trolling when he was full-on
conservative he didn't sound so
flamboyant
maybe he is infiltrating the left or
being a lefty some sort of sickness
or being a tribal or or as being tribal
contributes this to this factor
i don't know i could can i just say that
like i i'm not sure how i've
demonstrated being tribal like i
i'm fully willing to criticize both
sides here uh and i think that there are
plenty of flaws on both sides
both sides ism now geez yeah
oh man there's a lot of funny comments
but i can't read all of them
some of them are mean to me too mean to
me they're all mean to you
they're all too mean i won't say they're
all mean to you but they're all like
comments about you being misinformed or
something
okay well that's fair not all of them
i'm reading you know i mean i don't
expect i expect you know the majority i
didn't expect a lot of your audience to
uh
to love me necessarily so yeah i need to
be critical of other people man but how
hard is it to be
deeply introspective about your own
flaws how many people get online and
make videos and talk about their own
ignorance
very few very good points yeah we have a
tweet a message from
uh iahi gusak who's ukrainian who
basically said the things i was saying
about ukraine were well known before it
was reported in the u.s
and that uh you were unaware which thing
about which the the hunter biden
joe biden yeah like the the the viral
video about joe biden saying give me the
billion dollars otherwise you're fired
that's the kind of issue with with
censorship why didn't you see that video
that video was crazy viral
but it's because there's censorship and
suppression echo chambers
that video got false flags on facebook
and like
missing context flags which de-ranks it
in the algorithm
so simple answer yes it wasn't outright
banned though
and then like a lot of the fact tricks
are like well there's a lot of context
missing
and they say things like it was in line
with u.s policy to have this man fired
and it's like
and you know it was yeah they emailed
the state department and then joe biden
went and intervened yeah
it's funny how joe biden as soon as the
obama obama and biden get into office
and uh biden's put in charge of the
operations in iraq
his brother gets these contracts
politico wrote
an article called biden inc that maps
out
joe biden's positions and how his family
is just magically
right there to get all of the benefits
from it for 50 years
it's remarkable stuff so the way i put
it is yeah i think trump's played
uh uh i think i think trump's played
ignorantly dirty
like you know oh i'm gonna give it cost
that's a great deal it's like no dude
that's still you know
you're putting any money from the
government to your companies with your
control is a conflict of interest
you can't do that i also think people
like trump i said this before
have a kind of capitalist corruption to
them
i don't know that's the right way to put
it but to put it simply you guys ever
see back to school i think the name of
the movie with rodney dangerfield yeah
there's that scene where he's in the
college and the professor is like
you know giving a lecture on how to make
widgets or whatever and then he's like
this is all wrong
and he goes on and explains how you
actually run a business because he's
like this rich guy who went to college
and he's talking about you got to save a
couple bucks to grease the wheels the
inspector is going to come in
basically breaking down the dirty things
these businesses do to make a ton of
money
along the lines of trump lining his own
pockets with his political savvy i
is is him running his own personal
twitter account he doesn't use the potus
account
no that's a free speech issue um okay
but he's also as soon as he's not
president he now has he'll be back
80 million followers will be banned but
because of his time spent
in politics he's enriched his own
personal fame
and and i wonder and so is obama and so
everyone
obama i think that everyone who is
who's in public office though like
obviously gets more famous you could
argue that aoc
inflated her fame as well like she has a
personal account
but i don't think that donald trump yeah
aoc is her personal account yeah donald
trump gaining facts that's what she uses
from the twitter account i don't think
but building a that's an actual business
tool like building that as an asset
is kind of like should politicians be
building their assets like
well you want to make an argument about
politicians shouldn't be allowed to make
any money outside of public pay and
their pay should be tied to the median
income in this country
i'll have a conversation with you about
that we're tied to a public account of
some success no no i'm not worried about
small account you know what you know
what i like
i like if congress got paid the median
the median salary of the united states
and if there was ever a period in which
there was wide scale like government
shutdown then they shut themselves down
too if the government gets shut down
they don't get paid in order to raise
their salary they have to raise the
medium
the median salary of the united states
i'm not literally advocating for this
because there's actually arguments for
why we should pay
politicians ridiculous sums of money
because we don't want them to be
incentivized to do things outside if
like we told a politician
after you retire you're guaranteed like
a ridiculous sum of money they're going
to be like wow would i
risk losing this they might be going to
raytheon or monsanto right exactly yeah
i don't know that's necessarily true
though it's just there's some arguments
one of the arguments is tie their
salaries to the median salary of the
united states and they'll work
really hard to get that median salary up
and they'll be advocating for analysis
and
is is it up now is it up now you want to
raise average worker salaries have to be
up
but i don't even know that's a good idea
because then they'll just be like i
don't care if i get paid or not
you'll only get millionaires and
billionaires who are actually in office
than the people who don't care about the
money so that i think something that was
something andrew yang brought up that if
we give politicians a ridiculous sum of
money
you'll have middle class people being
like that's a good job
and i wouldn't want to risk it and then
you'll actually have an incentive for
people to want to stay there
it's it's an argument people don't
understand about non-profits too
people complain that see nonprofit ceos
get paid hundreds of thousands of
dollars
well sometimes millions they have to if
a non-profit is if they're still a
business if they're not competitive
they're not going to get good ceos
and if it's a non-profit that's got like
you know 3 000 employees
you've got a massive infrastructure
you're going to need to pay top dollar
for a good ceo
granted most of these non-profits i've
worked at i think they're all scams
that's just me most of charities are yep
uh china crypto says tim this guy has no
idea how economics works nor has he any
idea of how the world works
insane and insanely dumb super low iq
people being kols is one of the reasons
why social media is making the average
iq of the mass lower
now i just want to i just want to
mention if you're if you're saying you
left the right and you're coming on my
show you know
you know i apologize if people are going
to be you know
you know my little motto is the guy you
love to hate so that's
everywhere i go i get hate it's not
nothing i can't handle here
but also i think it's a little funny
when people say like you're a low iq but
then like
don't provide any counter yeah i don't
like just ad hominems
uh and sendit media says hunter is the
classic example of left winger who
simply thought he was right wing because
the left told me was
you can be a bigot on the left literally
every left country has been genocidal
yeah no that's just bull
i don't know if you're advocating for
the traditional family i would say
well no way because i'm not a lefty
right i have some positions that are in
line with right wing because like
i would argue that i'm more pro-life too
for example
um although the way to solve that i some
people say i'm still technically
pro-choice i guess but
i mean yeah no i i go after both sides
it's
there's a lot a lot of people are
commenting on the me going off on the
the zlatovsky thing the ukraine thing
yeah i would say that that i definitely
need to do a little more research well
but that i feel like that's really the
only little scuffle we had it's really
but you see you walked into this one
because you called it misinformation
and when i said you were wrong you kept
saying no well i had
i had heard completely the contrary to
the i had heard that
i i still listen i'm not able to like
fact check this in either so like i want
to look this up myself as well
i heard the video i know you said other
people are saying it's missing context
i'd like to know what that context is
the context is
that it was in line with u.s policy
that victor show can be removed from his
post as prosecutor
in i think prosecutor general actually
in in ukraine because he was viewed to
be
corrupt okay i mean yeah however it's
definitely something i'll look into for
sure
you know i need to get more info if
barack obama and joe biden are doing
crooked things to benefit themselves or
obama turns a blind eye they can just
say yeah i was in line with policy
because biden is the vice president and
he's doing it right they
they froze this guy's assets and then
eventually
they unfroze him so if anything what joe
biden did was make sure this guy
had a free couple of years with no heat
on his back but then when trump got in
this guy fled to monaco they think they
think monaco but uh
yeah i mean the simple the like i don't
even understand how we get to that point
with with charisma and stuff
it's just like joe biden's son got a job
on the board of a ukrainian energy
company
like man if people knew the context
around this so
uh wow you know what gazprom is
it's like there's so much going on to
where if you knew about the qatar turkey
pipeline
the the obama funding the the the uh the
rebels in syria
the the cutter carter pipeline funding
rebels in syria
going go uh no-fly zones overseer
targeting russia the conflict in libya
the natural gas monopoly out of gas prom
off you know all of this stuff ties
together
it sounds like hunter biden was placed
there if it if
when you put all these pieces together
now i'm i can't assert that i'm just
saying
that that that to me sounds like a
possibility they needed assets
in ukrainian natural gas and energy
because they were working on this plan
to subvert russia's monopoly
so when michael flynn and i learned this
from luke essentially exposed that obama
was arming rebels
that's why they accuse him of working
with the russians because they're like
why is he doing this it's russian
syria only refused to allow us to build
the pipeline because they said russia
told them not to let us do it
then they wanted to subvert our attempt
at building a pipeline then you get this
energy company in ukraine which is
key is in the key position to be the
company distributing the gas
into europe once they shut down the
russian monopoly and it's like
there's joe biden's son ready for that
sweet sweet skrill as soon as that
pipeline's finished
and there was a big revolution in
ukraine to try to decouple ukraine from
russia
and make it more favorable towards
europe and the european and it caused a
separatist movement which led to what
some called the civil war briefly and uh
i was there when it started they
exploited some corruption that was
happening between the russians and the
ukrainians and they replaced it with
new corruption that's happening right
now between europeans and americans and
ukraine right now and when you go to
ukraine i mean
those people are getting exploited and
robbed left and right by just
so much corruption that it's absolutely
mind-boggling to see it happen there to
to the extent
that it does it's interesting uh one way
to look at it is
european countries are being strangled
when it comes to natural gas
and they need these resources they need
to be you know have more access to to
energy
so the us is desperately trying to
assist its allies and getting energy
there
and you know these people and these
different families are
set to uh make a ton of cash off of it
i truly think donald trump is outside
the system anti-establishment
i'm i don't think he's the most selfless
person in the world i think his family
is going to benefit
greatly in some capacities but i do
think trump's net worth has dropped
dramatically
i think you know i think several hundred
million dollars since he became
president
so if i ultimately had if i ultimately
had to make a choice between
corrupt 47-year democrat politician
responsible for most of the or
i should say some of the racist laws
left has been complaining about
whose brother and son have somehow
gotten rich perfectly in line with joe
biden's like
oversight and then i look at donald
trump who's only been in office for now
just just under four years and
lost a net worth to a significant degree
i'm about to go with the trump guy
especially when he's trying to end the
wars and joe biden was part of the
administration that like created tons
more
but also very interestingly trump was
being investigated almost the entire
time that he was in office there was a
whole mueller investigation going
through every little thing he did
and i remember listening to npr just
yesterday and they were talking about
well
of course we're going to have to get all
the attorney generals we're going to
charge trump with so many different
charges
and then one of the legal experts like
well he's been under complete
investigation
for russian collusion and they went
through everything and they didn't
really find
that much and comparatively if you look
at institutionalized
politicians that been there for 50 years
like joe biden
there's a lot more corruption a lot more
wheeling and dealing
than there is with donald trump who just
kind of came into this swamp
i think it's all swamp monsters as far
as i can see swamp monsters all the way
down
but uh trump's trying to end the wars so
it's like i'm on board with that i just
i i just see trump i guess giving the
tax cuts to the corporations and uh the
way he sort of benefits what's wrong
with giving tax cuts to corporations
well because it hasn't done anything to
help
what do you mean to help like
corporations like only a small
percentage are massive multinationals
well like clearly not in favor of amazon
and like facebook
sure but by giving tax cuts to these
corporations it didn't do what it was
supposed to do and
i mean we americans were supposed to do
it was supposed to bring back more
companies
more corporations back from overseas uh
it was either that or it was to
encourage i think it was probably both
to bring companies from overseas and to
encourage
more people to like open their
businesses here in america with the with
the tariffs and the tax cuts ford
brought back three billion dollars into
uh
into michigan i just know that overall
it didn't it really didn't didn't do
what it was
intended to do and now us american
taxpayers are going to be the ones to
foot the bill
yeah there's tons of deficit spending
trump did campaign on
lowering the deficit and the debt and he
definitely did not happen that did not
happen at all money printer go burr
he's not anti-war either man this
expanded drone war is super concerning
yeah but you're talking about a long
time ago talking about a secret drone
war
luke can you tell me about how he's made
it so that he doesn't have to reveal who
he's drone well we don't know the full
extent of it because again we don't have
the record and the re
record keeping was uh canceled by him we
knew under barack obama how many drones
were sent out under donald trump we
don't know
um no new wars that drone
strikes one big problem well vietnam
wasn't a war
illegally no new wars is a bit of a low
bar to set however
that's scary scary that's true right he
expanded the secret of drone war
he expanded the drone war campaign i
think that's where i think we're gonna
find that early early on soon
donald trump was engaging in i would say
well i don't want to say substantially
but i think a significant number more
drone strikes than obama was that was
that was early on
and trump did probably the stupidest
thing i think anybody could do in
bringing on john bolton
that guy john bolton was like this time
next year with his bushy mushroom we're
going to be challenging in
tehran it's like wow first of all if you
really want to declare war on iran you
wouldn't go and announce we're going to
be invaded
in your city in a year second of all
iran
people don't realize this too iran is
not iraq or afghanistan
it is not some you know it is it is a
developed
powerful country with military resources
and i believe
one of the uh key assets of iran is
their anti-aircraft capabilities which
makes it very difficult for the us
because we rely on air superiority
so take a look at the military bases
that we've been building and it's like
perfectly set up around iran so then
trump decides to bring on the one guy
who wants to snap his fingers and
make it all worse not to mention yeah
that you know a lot of conservatives are
cheering about
you know the strikes targeting the
nuclear scientists and solomanian stuff
and it's all it's like
look i'm not going to pretend to have
access to classified information but i'm
definitely anti-escalation of conflict
and war so i'm never going to say that's
a good thing
however iran has been terrorizing people
and you know the persian gulf
it's just the cia installed the shah or
they are 1979 right yeah they overthrew
the democratic
people of iran and installed this
theocracy and now they're trying to
blame the theocracy and armed them you
have to understand when the
when iraq and iran was fighting the
united states military was arming both
sides
and with the latest iraq war it has
empowered iran geopolitically because
iraq used to be its main threat its main
enemy they got rid of that
the sphere of influence of iran spread
because of the first
because of the the latest iraq war which
is another contributing factor to
understand here the shah was the
democratically elected president and
then they installed ayatollah khamenei
is that
what happened yes yeah that's insane and
that is that like
been publicly disclosed well before that
happened
iran was kind of a civilized western uh
favorite kind of uh country where you
know
there wasn't any burqa mandates there
wasn't any islamic law there wasn't any
sharia law
people were were able to live like they
were able to live in europe
after the revolution after the overthrow
after the direct involvement of the cia
things took a turn for the worst and we
have a current state of iran
that is where it is today because of the
direct fingerprints of the quote deep
state
interesting it used to be the left that
was anti-deep state
and it was like you know i think the
nation dot com like lefty publication
and people like glenn greenwald were
like the deep state intelligence
agencies
that's why they loved snow that's why
they loved assange now it's like
the left is pro deep state basically
it went from the deep state as a
conspiracy to thank god the deep state
has stopped trump remember that article
well they're cheering on john bolton i
remember seeing a whole bunch of
democrats and liberals on twitter like
yes john bolton he's going to expose the
corruption and take down
i'm like you don't do you know who john
bolton is and his long
track record of just murder he like john
bolton is like
what was the movie where the uh uh the
guy rides the nuclear bomb down like
captain america no no you know i'm
talking about right yeah that old movie
yeah yeah what it's called doctor
strange doctor doctor strangelove yeah
john bolton is the guy who's gonna ride
the like the bomb all the way down like
right into iran like cheering and
yelling for it very happy
road worthy ink says wow tim i have to
say i'm a little disappointed you say
you only have relevant guests but then
bring this clueless kid on
weakest guest possible especially
following alex jones well i will say you
get to follow alex jones
but i will i will rebut saying i've no i
didn't say we
well if i did say we only have relevant
guests then i'll concede the error what
i mean to say is
we typically tend to try and make sure
guests are are particularly relevant
the reason hunter is on for one is
because someone had reached out to me
and they were like yo you know hunter
right i'm like yeah i'm like you should
have them i was like yeah we'll look
into it and then it turns out
you're super close and it was like
really easy right but i also
want to stress we've had probably like
what 10 people on this show who are like
i used to be on the left and then i left
and we've not had one person who's like
i used to be on the right and then i
left and so i was like oh this actually
does make a lot of sense so
uh that being said i think i know why
people are saying this
and y'all gotta calm down do you know
whether i know why they're saying it too
why i've seen some stuff on twitter i
know what's going on i know there are
people who want
particular guests
so the power went out again it's got to
be the wind
yeah yeah this thing's like getting
worse and worse every time the power
goes out
because like we're running all of this
stuff on one emergency backup battery
should we have a second or third one
we do we it's split between two
different loads got it so you're hearing
different beeping because they're both
at the same time but i think we need
more perspectives more opinions i think
we need to talk to each other more than
ever
and i thank you for coming here and
being able to share your
point of view and your perspective and
your opinions that we would never
understand if it wasn't for you coming
here well thanks man i really appreciate
that yeah
for sure so uh one person commented that
they think the only reason you've
changed your opinion on social issues
is because you have a big channel and
you're you're willing to shave off a
certain number of supporters if it means
you don't get banned
okay yeah i mean that's a very very
common argument that people make against
me
um but that's i don't know like how to
rebut that like it's just it's just not
true um
people well you know my youtube channel
was banned temporarily yeah i remember
that i remember that i think i tweeted
about it
yeah um didn't you speak at like a
mythicist thing too yeah i mean
yeah yeah like i i did a lot of stuff on
that kind of and
and did you speak at my event in philly
were you at the phillip philly one the
philly one was was put on by me in
partnership with the mythicist guys
at the casino i yeah i was at the casino
oh wow
i saw you walk by and i was like yo it's
time we didn't meet then that's funny
yeah that's cool but um
i've completely forgot my train of
thought now but i don't know
oh well i love how there's a combination
between people saying this is the worst
uh tim cast or the best is that what
they're saying i think
the people really love when i got angry
about the zlatsky stuff and like
getting very specific people like take a
clip of that and post it it's like yeah
but then other people are like this is
boring you suck okay
well that's how it's out you know it's
that's how it always guys
make everyone happy exactly rob grant
says tim i'm becoming an architect and i
can speak on plans to truly fix these
neighborhoods through investment and
pathways to ownership within the
community to help redlined areas
please let me come talk well uh send us
an email spin the ufo at gmail still our
email
uh you could have him send it to me too
uh what's your email lydia timcast.com
there you go and i'm happy to share that
all right let's see you know honestly i
i i would have liked to gonna
go on a lot longer but considering the
power keeps shutting off i think that's
like the eighth time i think
yeah seriously and you can't keep
flipping the breakers that like you're
it's really really cool we got win
everything it was snowing today for the
first time in the year
makes me think we got to get solar we
got to prioritize it well this is a
breaker issue we're going to run
specifically
out again you guys can send me to go
okay next time we'll go together all
right so we'll do a couple more of these
super chats
uh let's see oh someone i just lost it
that was a really good one
i have to find it do it by memory no
it's gone that's unfortunate
now i want to know what the really good
one was i am a gorilla
gabriel logan says tim forearms huge are
they
what no i think it's just a camera thing
yeah it's perspective perspective
and you accused me of going on that
adult website
oh my gosh luke shout out to newborn are
we really bringing that about yeah
apparently from pornhub or
all right let's see outlaw bear says
this is the best tim cast irl ever
because he's taking an
uninformed normie and breaking him down
the news guard and breaking him
down the news guard in rip guard
breaking him down with news guard in
real time
hunter was out of his league tonight
like hunter b in china
i don't know i also think too like you
do cultural commentary right yeah i do a
lot more social stuff yeah coming into
like a hard political space is not
advantageous and i i will admit that
yeah a lot of the topics we talked about
today i
i wasn't like the uh uh hunter binding
thing's a perfect example stuff i'm not
particularly educated in as opposed to
a lot more of the social issues kenneth
raymie says i was raised in a home where
my parents were gay
what people failed to see from a child's
point of view i grew up keeping friends
away because i didn't want them knowing
i'm not anti-lgbtq but kids do see
things differently
that was your point actually social
stigma yeah that's
i would argue that that needs the social
stigma needs to change not the gay
couples i think it is changing
i think oh yeah absolutely yes i mean
gay acceptance of gay people is
steadily going up yeah for sure jamie
mccarthy says does biden end up
impeached due to hunter investigation
you may have spoken to this but i just
tuned in
um maybe that's the plan maybe they say
oh no
you know he's got to go and then he he
says okay fine this has become too much
i'm resigning and then comment becomes
president
and then he gets pardoned yeah yeah yeah
yeah or he'll just die from covet guys
possibly yes all right let's see here we
got a big one what's this
brian murdock says i'm a tax lawyer at
pwc
trump did not write the tax reform tax
lawyers did and the reform were
patrioted trillions of dollars
that was trapped in irish and lux tax
havens it lowered taxes for individuals
and corpse alike
read about gi lti and the toll change
love y'all
interesting there you go very cool
thanks dude
let's see wait what
i don't know that was okay let's do uh
let's do one more super chat
also let's do a couple leila says really
like this guest tim i agree with you
hunter on quite a bit but disagree
on most of these issues appreciate you
coming on peace see there you go there
you go
uh salty tamale says honestly hunter
wasn't a narcissist like vosh
[Laughter]
oh wow demon rush says this guy the guy
you love to hate
very humble hunter thank you tim your
show is awesome moved away from chicago
recently after 19 years of growing up
there
it's painful walking away from the city
but it's changed so much
a guy named tim great name says this is
my first super chat and it's to white
knight for hunter he's a good kid and
open-minded
if he's if uh if he's so close bring him
on more yeah we absolutely could
appreciate uh well i think considering
what the power is going to go out soon
again we made it we made it two hours
yes the power went out right before we
started it's got to be the high wind
somehow
i guess because this is not normal we do
the show all the time when the power
went out did we lose the stream
every time a couple times but i switched
to satellite so the quality went down a
little bit but then the stream stayed on
the lights turned off
we'll get it sorted we'll call it
electrician asap but i think we'll be
fine by tomorrow
i think someone might be hogging the
circuit somewhere else too because
we unplugged everything it's still going
down you know what that means tim you're
gonna have to have me on again yeah yeah
like a rematch yeah
a rematch a rematch well i think you
know on cultural issues it's kind of
just like
when it comes to cultural opinions like
i agree i disagree well then you know
it's like a couple yeah the zelda
zlatski thing is super niche i would
venture to wage that 99.999 percent of
americans have never
i've read i read all the affidavits and
your audience has heard about it i've
read
intensely four years of news
from all of the mainstream outlets to
ukrainian outlets
to even russian attempts at like proper
you know propaganda
and the sworn affidavits there was one
period where they were trying to get uh
biden named as a as
a wanted felon like a court issued a
ruling there was a
official ruling from a court in ukraine
that said ukrainians did interfere in
the 2016 election to hurt donald trump
that was that was new york times
reporting that so all that stuff
happened anyway
not to rehash that uh how about uh
hunter you got any you want you want to
give a shout out to your youtube channel
anything like that for people who
who did like you yeah sure for the for
the couple people here that did like me
i
appreciate it um yeah you can follow me
just on hunter
hunter avalon is my youtube channel it's
the same username pretty much on every
social media platform too
easy enough right on yeah you can follow
me on twitter instagram and parlor at
tim cast
you can check out my other youtube
channels youtube.com timkasten
youtube.comcastnews we are live monday
through friday at 8pm
smash that like button it really really
does help and uh
give us a good review on itunes or
spotify you know we do really well on
itunes we're actually one of the top
global podcasts but on spotify for some
reason
not a whole lot of traction it's weird i
don't understand why but uh if you guys
do wanna listen on spotify we're there
and uh check us out luke do you wanna
yeah my youtube channel is we
are change and before ian graciously
brings this up oh you know
if you want to purchase any of the
clothing that i usually wear on this
show you can
on teesprings.com forward slash stores
forward slash we are change and that
goes to supporting me so thank you
we're going to have merch very very soon
we're getting a website done it's going
to be vip content we're going to have
stuff for the vlog we're gonna have
bonus segments with guests
it's gonna be a lot of fun and that's
gonna be for remember so that's coming
soon too
ian you wanna get a little bit of
special merch i'll be teasing in the
near future as well
i'm not gonna tell you what it is we
gotta get a shirt with ian's face on it
definitely luke i love the santa hat
thank you it's like a five-year-old
santa hat
i think it turned you blue yeah i saw a
we are change video earlier and you had
the santa hat on i was
excited like five years every every
december i wear it
oh yeah i like it he does do you wear it
like why don't you sleep too and stuff
no no no no super filthy can i ask you a
quick question before you know what the
question is
do you go to sleep in your beanie yes no
of course not
when you came here was i wearing a
beanie no that's right i was actually a
little surprised to be
like who is this yeah uh do i know you
people
it's actually really funny we had a
guest come over once i'm not gonna say
what it was
and when i skate i don't wear i if if
i'm filming and skating i i'll wear a
beanie just to like you know
but if i'm just like skating exercising
sometimes i'll wear even shorts but i'll
usually wear just like some ratty
clothes i'm going to tear up and i'll
wear a sweat band
somebody came in and it was the guest
for the show and i walked up i was like
how's it going and they're like hey hey
and then i was like nice to meet you and
they're like oh and i'm like did you not
recognize me and he was like
oh oh oh yeah i'm not going to say who
that was though but it was really funny
is it the other house
yeah because people can't record they
didn't recognize me it was like whoa i
didn't realize
uh anyway thanks for hanging everybody
don't forget to follow at sour patch
lids as well because she's over there
pushing all the buttons and twisting
knobs yeah
twisting twisting the knobs and pushing
the buttons and sometimes typing
we will be back tomorrow at 8pm live
and again smash the like button on your
way out thanks so much for the super
chats
we will see you all tomorrow at 8 pm all
right bye guys
you